it being 10 o'clock i'm going to call to
order
the house administration i'm sorry
the house executive department
administration hearing on house bill
representative likus is going to
introduce the legislation for us be the
sponsor or none of the co-sponsors are
here
right i'm just going to introduce it
it's not my bill i'm not going to answer
any questions on it um
so i'd like to introduce house bill 1062
relative the duties of the electrology
so
if you would like to
great
thank you
so i think chair maguire is another
meeting i think she's introducing
another bill uh she asked me to make an
announcement that
since at least two members and it looks
like more not going to be here we're not
house recognizes
courtney executive director of plc
um
i wish to thank representative mcguire
for bringing this bill forward this is
essentially just a cleanup bill
as it currently stands electrology
advisory committee is one of our four
advisory boards that makes
recommendations to the office regarding
licensure and regulation
the statute currently requires that the
members of the three-person advisory
panel actually administer examinations
this is inconsistent with
the way
the majority of our other boards
administer exams and inconsistent with
with how other states administer exams
so we'd like to eliminate that
requirement so that we can actually
contract out for such services
be happy to answer any questions is a
pretty basic bill
happy to answer anything any questions
i was actually trying to get um
gourley
goalie representative goalie
and then fellows
is the
advisory uh committee okay with these
changes
the advisory committee hasn't met for a
long time so we haven't convened a
quorum and i don't know their position
we have
we did meet several months ago to advise
the rules with the understanding that we
would contract up for such
services
their primary concern at the time even
though we didn't have a vote was who
would administer the practical
examinations and i told them that i
would research what other states are
doing and get back to it
right now i have received one
resignation so we only have uh one
currently appointed i think to the
electrology advisory committee there are
only 60 licensees so that's part of the
reason behind these changes is to ensure
you recognize for follow-up well i
understand there's only 60.
i want to be clear that
they're going to be
part of the advisory on to how the exams
are done and who's hired out and it's
not just under the oplc's decision to
determine who's the best for this is yes
representative fellows
thank you
so
i don't know if you know this or not but
um the committee's received emails in
the last day or two and they said that
they were in the there were was a letter
from somebody who was on that advisory
board
and she said
that
they were not notified of this bill
and given your role to support boards
can you explain to me how that
came to be yep so all of our
i mean i can't speak to that
specifically all of our bill tracking
went out
it should have gone out
this
it should be going out today because i i
input it all into the system and send it
out to all the board members or the
board administrators over the weekend
we had have conversations with them but
we have had difficulties convening a
quorum to have a meeting so um
by virtue of the fact that the board
members have declined to come in person
so
as you know i cannot i cannot
communicate with the board member via
email because that would constitute a
recognize for follow-up
so that raises two more questions in my
mind what why
why are the
no tracking information going out like
not yet so you're basically confirming
that you didn't notify them
and
um
don't don't you have the opportunity to
hold to set up board meetings remotely
no
um it's a requirement of 91a that a
quorum be physically present in order to
conduct meetings
and
that has been in a primary issue with
this board in that two out of the three
members
and i will say i've received resignation
so we do not currently have a full
electronic electoral electrology
advisory committee at present
but when it was fully staffed i could
not convene a quorum because they
chose not to come into the building in
person to conduct business
um regarding your your first question um
i agree it was late obviously we've had
staffing issues i just we just finally
hired a general counsel but at the same
time this advisory committee is we are
able to act without
representative grota
thank you
i miss courtney i just want to make sure
that
those people who are
seeking licenses in electrology
will be given an exam that they have a
competitive competency exam so that we
know that they're going to qualify to
practice in new hampshire
yes
so that's been one of the concerns with
this hot current hodgepodge approach
with having board members administer
exams
it's it's not conducive to having a
timely licensure as you know under
541a29a we are required to
act within 60 days
given the current structure i'm not
confident that that could be
accomplished
that's why i would like to contract
operate services much like other states
we actually already have a contract in
place that
with i think it's pearson vue who
administers our cosmetology exams in
accordance with the criteria established
by the board
and it includes electrology but we have
not been able to utilize that contract
because of these statutory provisions so
you know i fully anticipate having a
contract established by requirements
based on advice of the electrology
committee but the individual could go
and contact
the exam service provider and staff you
know set up an exam time frame rather
than having to wait for a board member
recognize for follow-up yes thank you
so that anyone
new
to this coming to new hampshire will be
required to take this exam and i just
want to make sure that the exam that the
new exam
will be
at least the same standard as the old
one
representative goalie
thank you madam chair
i
have a question as to
it was my understanding when we first
set up oplc and there are some members
in this room that were around when this
happened and others who weren't familiar
with it at all that oplc was supposed to
be support to the boards and the boards
maintain their autonomy as to the
profession they regulated
my question is i thought i just heard
you state that you can go ahead and do
things without their consent and if
that's the case i have an issue with
that if you would believe it's i just
that wasn't the reason oplc was set up
in the original
setup and i think members in this room
may be able to
either clarify or
if i may um
this profession is different because the
statute gives direct regulatory
authority to the executive director
there are four professions that do that
it's the body art
reflexology
ophthalmic dispensers there's actually
no board and
a massage as well as
electrology the electrology advisory
committee has no independent regulatory
authority that's by the statute that's
very different from the other 50 boards
and i would agree with you
representative the other 50 boards our
job is to support the boards and their
independent regulatory
rulemaking authority but the electrology
advisory committee has no independent
regulatory authority and that is the
distinction and that's why i made that
statement because it's the agency itself
that directly regulates electrologists
representative fellows
so
uh you just stated that the
the exam
qualification process that you envision
is not going to change
they're going to have to take a test and
yes representatives
you're correct so that's how we handle
it with cosmetology so if you can
imagine with all of the cosmetologists
that get licensed the board does not
administer exams we contract working
with the board we contract it's actually
with prometric
and they have uh staff who the person
can call and make an appointment they
hold exams every day they can go and
they can do the written exam at their
convenience and then they also have
practical examinations that are staffed
by cosmetologists estheticians
and they adhere to the requirements
established by the board and it can be
done in a faster manner and with a
contract in place they're held
accountable obviously so um we
anticipate a similar situation uh with
the electrologists that the licensee
could go in and do their written and you
know in front of a computer being
monitored at their convenience and then
the practical exam the same thing
they could go in and
hello uh i have
somewhere along your testimony
way back you said something you're not
permitted by law to do something that
just caught my ear what was that would
you mind repeating what you're not
permitted to do by do you recall that
part of your testimony yes i do
representative it was to have remote
meetings per the states right to no law
rsa 91a a quorum of a regulatory body
must be physically present in order to
make decisions and convene a quorum
obviously that's been an issue with our
licensing boards as of late in that
you have anybody else have any further
questions representative fellows
thank you
so
you've told us that there are 60 people
who hold a license for electrology
are there are there people who
is that electrology ever combined with
any of the other
no so there's only 60 people in the
whole state who are qualified to
move remove hair
with the electrolysis process okay so so
how is it
that um
you will be able to find
somebody to
uh give the practical exam
in new hampshire and tell me about this
contracting place like what if somebody
lives up in littleton or are you going
to tell them they have to come all the
way down to manchester or how's that
going to work
um it's going to work how it works for
other professions and that you know
whatever contract and i don't i can't
say it would be prometric or
petersonview or whatnot but there are
companies that specialize in providing
exam services and they have locations
all over the place
so typically the person would have to go
to whatever the testing center is
closest to them and there would be
somebody qualified to administer the
exam you can appreciate that if i'm
having trouble getting people coming
into the building to administer a
practical that i have i have a realistic
concern that somebody
under the current structure um could
reach out to a board member who may not
be available within the 60-day time
frame and that is that's really the gist
any other members have any other
questions
seeing none we thank you for your
testimony thank you madam chair do you
have written testimony would you like me
to provide that to you
certainly we can give it to the clerk
okay
madam check one one more quick question
if i may
representative cool are you recognized
just a quick question on line 12 of the
bill
sure
why are you striking the content and
conduct of written and practical exams
and just leaving it written in practical
exams
hold on sorry i don't have it in front
of me
what was your question representative
line 12 yeah striking out the con
content and conduct of
why is that being removed because if
you're doing the looking at the exams it
should include those shouldn't it
the concern is that we're not present
they have a statutory requirement right
to provide input which means they have
to convene a quorum which which they
have not been doing um so without a
quorum we would not be able to make
recommendations
or create an exam now if that were not
this the case statutorily we could
certainly receive input from one or two
members and provide that input into any
sort of requirement section but the fact
that we're currently required to convene
a quorum which is not happening because
they're not physically coming into the
building that puts us at um
we're not actually able we would not be
permitted to actually contract for those
services
you recognize or follow mr
representative goalie
i'm looking under the rule making
authority
on
chapter 314 and it says the exec
executive director shall adopt rules
pursuant to and then under it is roman
numeral 3 the content in conduct so
that's under your rule-making authority
so i'm just
don't understand why
content and conduct would be
removed
it has nothing to do with the board it
has to do with the executive director's
authority
um actually i think those are board
requirements uh representative that they
actually be um
that they actually be physically present
in order to make decisions on the
conduct and the content of the
examination
we're kind of at a standstill with some
of our licensing boards particularly
this one as well and that we can't make
any decisions because of the statutory
requirement that the
that particular board provide input on
on those issues and there and we're not
under 91a able to make any decisions
so that's what that was intended to
address
any other members have any other
questions
representative schuett thank you not a
question but um
just offer my apologies to the committee
and to our chair
i had promised her that i would
introduce this and
due to unforeseen circumstances i was a
your apologies accepted no need to
apologize would you like to testify on
this bill representative schuett
we we did not have a representative to
testify for it
uh well as a co-sponsor i will just say
that we have
i think you've all gotten some emails
from
folks in this profession who are a
little concerned about this
several of the bills that we had agreed
to make advisory
and
we're hearing from the various boards
that
they're not
too happy with that
i just will let it go at that on this
one i have
more to say on some of the other ones
if you can excuse me for one minute
representative
we still have a we still have a person
that was testifying does anybody have
representative are you okay so we just
we've actually i do believe we excuse
you but i you're still in the hot seat
i may be a little bit off topic but if
the board
can't
meet
are they also unable to perform
electrolysis
well that's a good question i would have
to ask them um
they it's not that they can't meet it's
that they've declined to physically come
into the building
and that would be
my response to members of the board who
are concerned with this
is that if they actually would like to
regulate they need to come in and
regulate and do their job
and right now
we have not um
we had redrafted all of the electrology
rules i attempted to convene a quorum so
that we could get their input and i had
one person show up and didn't receive
any feedback
so that's where we're at right now which
is that
i've got a non-functional board that
insists on retaining certain authority
but doesn't actually wish to carry out
the functions that they presently are
required to do so under statute so we
can't actually make any changes that are
beneficial to our constituents and our
licensees and actually protect the
public
representative scitec did i just
understand that in that last minute you
really explained the whole situation
yes i tried to avoid that quite
diplomatically but at the end of the day
representative schuett
thank you a question does occur um
miss courtney is it not true that um
the gentleman asked whether or not these
people are pursuing their professions
but would it not be true that when they
are pursuing their profession
they can sort of control the atmosphere
where they're working whereas if they
come into the building where they would
have to meet
with yours they cannot control the
situation i'm speaking about face masks
or cleanliness
sure yes we obviously as a stay per um
state requirement we cannot require
anybody to wear masks or face masks but
we have done everything that we can do
to accommodate boards that have concerns
our staff willingly done on face masks
we don't have these issues with the
board of medicine they're all providers
we don't have this issue with the board
of nursing they're all you know
clinicians as well
they all the majority of them wear masks
and our staff do too and we are happy as
always to find meeting space not in our
building
if that's their preference
we had this issue come up with court
reporters recently we offered to meet in
the courtyard
that was declined so you know we can
only do so much i understand that people
feel uncomfortable but at the end of the
day government can't stop
further questions recognize for
follow-up representative schuett thank
you um
do you think that the effects of the
pandemic
had any effect on the ability to get
more board members to participate not
only this board but several of the
others
i think that's probably true i think
that um
when we moved remote back in i think
april yes april 2020 we removed the
boards
to remote meetings via the governor's
executive order
um at first
you can appreciate that nobody like you
know everybody has something to complain
about when we make decisions at oplc you
can't please 350 people but a lot of
them were not happy because they didn't
know how to use the technology and yada
yada
then i think they got used to it and the
fact that they didn't have to drive to
concord um it was very convenient
particularly for working professionals
um
it is more convenient and then um
when obviously that executive order
ended that permitted them to uh have
remote meetings in may of 2021 again
everybody complained
um i think that it's been difficult for
retention both in the fact that uh you
know it's hard to
get working professionals to take a
whole day off to drive down to concord
um as well as the fact that some people
obviously rightfully so may
remain concerned about exposure
and but yeah yeah i certainly think that
that has helped i mean the good thing is
that they've they've embraced a
different technology that i don't think
they would have
thank
you representative grota
thank you i would like to make a note to
the committee first that you need to
speak directly into your microphone
and i know it sounds loud but people who
are listening to the youtube video
cannot hear us if we talk like this
all right
my question to miss courtney is if the
board is not
um
if they're having a bad day
can those board members be replaced
certainly they can be replaced um
presently the statute it's a little
unclear as to because
i appointed these board members they're
not governor and council appointments
one of our issues just generally just to
throw it out there is once a board
member's on you can't get them off
unless they're impeached even if they
don't show up which is which is a huge
problem um and as you know an
impeachment is unlikely to occur
the uh with these advisory board members
it's not actually clear what authority i
have
to
either force a resignation or to
remove them
my gut tells me there would need to be
some sort of a hearing because there was
an appointment um in place
so
unless we typically ask for resignations
um but i have had people who i just had
somebody on a different committee hasn't
shown up in a year has i've
sent her certified letters
we filed a complaint against
somebody for not showing up because she
had state documents and she has declined
to submit her resignation so um to your
question representative i don't really
know right now and and i do i did just
receive a resignation so i am able to
able to fill that seat which is which is
good
any other members have any other
questions
sing none
just a friendly reminder when you're
tested when you're asking a question if
you could please speak directly into
your microphone the audio appears to be
a little bit sketchy today and people
are having trouble hearing online
are there any other members from the
public that wish to testify for house
seeing none i'll close the hearing on
house bill 1062. oh my god i didn't even
see you representative schmidt i was
looking but
my nickname in the marine corps used to
be superman
but
i was never known as the invisible man
before
in any case uh i'm
seeing that representative maguire was
unable to be with us this morning as a
prime sponsor
but i'm on the bill so i
didn't feel comfortable um
asking questions from the bench so to
speak
excuse me
um but
i i in it's important for the committee
members to understand that one of the
things that we're doing
is
is we are attempting to assist the
executive director in
reorganizing the way
oplc functions a number of the senior
recognized that
there are certain deficiencies that were
kind of built into oplc at the time it
was constructed
which have served as an impediment
for the
good order and discipline if you will of
oplc and the functionality and so we are
starting on
a small group of
boards
some of the some of the bills
will be coming up shortly
and we are attempting to get more
functionality by having
the
oplc
more thoroughly
handling the
administration aspects
this was referenced before by
representative goldie
but also to have the
the
members of the profession
concentrate more and be more restricted
in terms of
dealing only with the
the profession itself
rather than the administration of the
profession because in many cases we have
discovered that
the board members frequently may not be
aware of all the legal requirements such
as
1991a
and other requirements of
a procedure
and which would be better handled by
the
oplc
and as you see in this particular
instance and i'm hoping representative
mcguire will
supplement this now that she's arrived
but that
the some of the senior members of edna
are on this bill so rehearsal mcguire
representative schuett myself
and in some cases it's representative
goldie as well
so
i do notice that one of the language and
i'm
glad that the director courtney's still
here because as you noticed if you look
line 10
it says
continuing life
the following the thought of
line three the executive
executive director shall establish and
so forth and then says in line 10 advise
the executive director regarding
implementation of this chapter and i'm
glad to hear that under this proposed
language the executive director would be
in direct contact with the executive
director uh that would be a presumption
on my part that we wouldn't want to have
three faces of eve uh and all kind of uh
getting involved here
so we might want to change that language
a little bit
but
so if anyone has any questions uh i i
would
hope they would defer
until representative mcguire can give
thank you representative schmidt does
anybody have any questions for the
representative
good morning i'm carol maguire
representing merrimack district 29 the
towns of allenstown epsom and pittsfield
i sponsored house bill 1062
at the request of the oplc
it is intended to have the oplc
provide all the administrative
and
non-technical
duties of the board and allow the board
to concentrate on the job specific
issues that require knowledge of the of
the
of the profession and that's
there are three
so that's uh it makes it an advisory
committee rather than a regulatory board
that's all it is
i hope you will support it
and if you have any questions i believe
oplc is here to answer them
do any members have any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
representative
are there any other members from the
public that wish to testify for house
our next bill isn't until 10 45 so we
will be in recess for approximately 15
minutes
um
i'm wondering i would like to schedule
1535 the cola bill
as soon as we possibly can the earliest
i think i can do is friday and i want i
already asked representative goalie i'm
hoping if we can get a location
to do it to have
at least the first round
it may take more than one
friday
i heard friday afternoon now
representative gola you said you're
i want as many people here as i can
this is this is an important bill i
i had said to representative goalie and
i'll repeat it um
we can vote it up or down but i don't
want to i don't want it either way
i'd be happy to i will not be happy to
win and not be happy to lose
i think this this needs some work i
think something can be done
and that's why i want representative
goalie i'm looking for representatives
schmidt they're the heavy hitters and i
think we should have their input whether
so
okay how about let me see if i can get
friday afternoon one o'clock
i'm sorry
okay all right i will ask um our uh
carrie if that's to to make that
schedule okay uh
representative goalie i know that it's
on it will be on the docket but if i
don't have art beaudry's uh email if you
have it you you i
you might be somebody that has artboard
oh wait a minute he's a lobbyist he's
going to be on the uh he'll yeah okay
i'll track him down because i i want him
good morning it's 10 45. i'm opening the
hearing
on
house bill 1065.
the sponsor has written us a nice letter
because she can't be here today
um
if
if you are going to introduce the bill
oh
yes
good morning everyone uh thank you for
your attention i'll be very briefly i'm
only going to open the bill on behalf of
representative nutterupum who is
unable to be with us
as a result of a
close encounter with the
omicron virus
so anyway i'm pleased
to open house bill 1065
relative to the regulation of art
therapists
this is a bill that
deals with a subject matter that we have
dealt with
in edna several times in the past
and
so i'm sure we'll explore it in the
course of
the thing and maybe i just better
i'm not going to read the representative
nutter oppam's
um
testimony but i urge you to read it
yourselves
um because
this is a very useful
therapy that uh
that is beneficial
i have a constituent in in dover
who operates uh so-called sanotina
center
uh in dover and she says that
she has a very strong
public demand for these services at the
moment
and uh so we'll get into the details
later on but i urge you to um
look carefully at representing dr
britton testimony and thank you very
much i'll fill out a pink card as soon
as i'm done
thank you representative schmidt could
you take a question
sure i'll give it a try representative
blackis
thank you you mentioned someone else
speaking later so maybe this would be to
someone else but i don't i don't see who
it would be so my question is um
you know the art therapists are
currently um licensed in some way and
this would put them under um
under the uh the mental health
board no they are not licensed they have
their
title protected
we have defined what an art therapist is
and we restrict who can call themselves
an art therapist ah thank you that
answers my question yeah is that the
chair is quite correct that we did
provide that protection for them in one
of the early go rounds
one of the problems is because they are
not licensed in many cases they are not
uh able to be
covered by insurance
because the insurance companies require
people to be licensed they're fully
accredited and they this is a
substantial enterprise nationally it's
just that without the licensing they've
got that
can't get there from here phenomenon
is there anyone else who wishes to
thank you madam chair this is
representative bellows i just wanted to
um say
a few things for the people who haven't
who are just new
this term because we had this bill
um we had this bill last
session last term
and
the
and um
prior to that
the
bill passed in 2018 and the in the one
that protected the title
that particular part of the statute
what it does is it says nobody can call
themselves an art therapist unless they
have met a whole list of qualifications
including at least
i think they need a master's degree so
you could look at that
and then
last term
we had this bill it passed this
committee
it passed the house
and due to covid it never got a hearing
in the senate
so that's one of the reasons it's come
it's coming up again
so
that's just those are just a couple of
points i just wanted to share for the
people who
thank you representative
is there uh represent
are there any questions
seeing none
director uh
doesn't think i trust you're going to
thank you madam chair yes i can't stay
silent i guess on a licensure bill
lindsey courtney executive director oplc
oplc doesn't take a position on whether
licensure is needed for art therapists
although
i do want to throw out there that we've
had um
we've we've increased the number of
licenses over the last couple years
primarily for reimbursement
and i think at some point we probably as
a state need to resolve the issue we
shouldn't be
from my perspective
licensing individuals that don't
necessarily need to be licensed just so
that they can receive reimbursement i
don't know what the solution is because
i know that involves insurance and
that's outside my wheelhouse but
licensure really isn't intended to
protect the public not to provide a
mechanism for reimbursement but i
understand it's a concern and
maybe this is the short-term fix so we
don't take a position the only thing
that i wanted to note was that on page 2
line 21 regarding fees
this bill
purports to
transfer
fee setting authority back to the board
the committee may be aware that there's
been an ongoing
issue with fee setting authority and
that in 2018
the authority of the boards to establish
fees was transferred to the office
but the language was retained in the
statute of the practice acts so we have
um we've been at a bit of a standstill
in terms of fee setting authority and
and we have a bill in place this year
that i think would clean that up and we
would just have concerns
of fee setting authority being
transferred back to the boards only
because
we're not able to actually
provide
a proportionate allocation of shared
costs when the office itself is not able
to set all of the fees for all the
boards um it impacts uh
allocations and it could impact you know
the fact that some boards could be over
125 some could be well under 100
so those are the only comments and i'd
you know be happy to work with anybody
to revise that if that was
if the committee was so inclined happy
thank you are there any questions
representative fellows
i i just have a question about the fee
that you were just talking about so to
address your concern wouldn't you
want to amend
make a bigger i mean taking art
therapist
out of here wouldn't solve your problem
that you were describing correct you
want to do that for all the boards
so
correct that actually
in 2000 i think it was 2018 um
the
legislature passed language that
transferred all of the board's fee
setting authority to the office
but when they did that they didn't
remove the language from the board
practice act that says you know the
board shall establish fees
so technically legally as the practice
acts have been amended we incorporated
that language after 2018 the boards
actually have the authority and not the
office this has been an issue at jail
car
and actually jail car
voted on a declaration to
confirm essentially that oplc has the
fee setting authority
but we're presently trying to clean up
the statutory language to remove
all of the
language that says the board shall
establish fees for all of the practice
acts just to make clear that the office
can establish fees
because right now we have several boards
that are paying way more than 125
percent we have some boards that aren't
meeting costs um
and obviously that's concerning if
they're paying more than 125 that's an
unconstitutional tax and we'd like to
resolve that problem but without the
ability to adopt fees across the board
for all boards at the same time using
the same allocation method uh we're not
able to do that so on an amendment i
would just remove reference to the board
chow and i would say you know the office
shell because that's that's the
authority that was granted to the office
in 310a
yes
if we were to pass this we would want to
make an amendment to delete the comment
about the boards
the fee set by the board they do have to
pay the fee but it's not set by the
board
any other questions comments
all right does any other member of the
public
no i guess not
all right
anyone else need to testify
in that case i'm going to close the
public hearing
and our next hearing starts at 10 30.
excuse me 11 30 my mistake um so we have
a bit of i was expecting this to take
longer
but but the with the sponsor not here
it's
okay
we'll not be voting on any bills today
because
it being 11 30 i'm going to call to
i'm sorry i'm going to go to order house
bill 1192
representative mcguire
good morning i'm still carol mcguire
representing merrimack district 29
which is the towns of allenstown epsom
and pittsfield
and house bill 1192 is primarily a
repeat of a bill
in 1920 that died in the senate it
passed this committee it passed the
house
and it died in the senate so we're
repeating it
um
it
various
sections
it allows a person who's a doctor or
acupuncture to call themselves that
and it eliminates the requirements for
nccaom
certification and training because
that is
only one of multiple
very narrowly specialized there are
different types of acupuncture that they
can people can learn other
so it adds
light
licensing
by
having a valid license from another
state
someone else whatever
or equivalent certification
the calif california has
a very
thorough
and
generous california acupuncture
the qualifications whatever
and what else
number of different changes recommended
and it's on page 2 line 17 it it
specifically adds
a internship program which is how most
people learn acupuncture in the first
place
so
as long as you have a balanced
clinical training and
on the acupuncture detox specification
it allows the general supervision to be
a
physician or an osteopath which is also
a doctor because
[Music]
the
requirement for the site visits
pass the authorization for ear
acupuncture for
detoxification
basically it's for it's for sanitary
reasons
but
i also have a letter from
the
board of
new hampshire acupuncture and asian
medicine association which is in support
of the bill
except they don't think
a physician would be appropriate
in section six
so
we can take that into advisement i'd
like to have this entered into the into
the record i will try to answer
questions
representative lekis
so um
on section six you're just speaking
about it just adds as i read it as a
physician or osteopath
to the people to the acupuncturist who
could do the site visit right is that
correct that's correct so they're
objecting to uh to allowing the
physician or osteopath rather than an
acupuncturist
[Music]
they say that such oversight goes beyond
the needs of acupuncture practitioners
and patients
but i think that the point of it is that
if you can't get an acupuncturist to
check that you're
using sterile you know proper
cleanliness and sanitation issues
a doctor or actually probably a
nurse would be just as good
okay thank
you representative schuett
thank you madam chair
um representative do you have an inkling
as to
why the previous bill died in the senate
was it just due to the pandemic or were
there issues raised i didn't hear of any
issues it never got a hearing it just
went away so likely because of the
if if i may inquire about a question i'm
representative mcguire
and i apologize if i should know this
and i don't
where it says three
has completed a valid internship program
three years minimum
is that also a certain amount of hours
not necessarily some some
sometimes we give a number of hours
sometimes we give it you know months or
years it depends on the profession
but
it's up to them if they think years is
the appropriate measure that's fine
the electricians like ours because they
like to work overtime and
cut the number of months and years down
thank you representative fellows
thank you
um i
i don't have any issues with the intent
but when i start to read
um section
four
i get confused
with it with that like ands and the oars
and just that kind of logic because it
starts out on line 26
that will issue a license to an
applicant who satisfies all
of the requirements yes you have to
follow the
logic
in this case they have to be 21 which i
personally would be willing to eliminate
and then they have to do b which is
certification
d
or
they have the
of age certification
has earned a baccalaureate or as a nurse
or
so
uh a is age
b is certification
and c is
c paid the fee very important
and d has earned a
this is education
so it's either
or has successfully completed
post-secondary acupuncture college
program
approved by the board or has a valid
internship
i'm still getting confused
because d is
baccalaureate and and has a current
balance license from another state
right so they have a baccalaureate or
are a nurse or physician assistant
with a valid license to practice
acupuncture or have taken
post-secondary acupuncture college
program board approved
or has a valid internship program
so there are
and i agree it's not the cleanest way to
put it i would probably have put
the
acupuncture college program
first then the
education in other areas that also has
an acupuncture license from another
state or has the internship
but so just like one tiny question so on
on the first page
b
that certification
they can get that certification or or
or a different certification approved by
the board so everybody has to do that
correct
regardless of whether they're they have
a
baccalaureate degree or those other
okay
yes so it's age
certification and education
and of course paying the fee okay
thank you
representative lakis
thank you um
thinking back on some earlier discussion
today should the dollar amount of the
license fee be in here or should it be
set by the
executor of oplc i believe executive
thank you for catching that
and
i will
i i agree we should be
we should be having that be
rewarded if we make any changes at all
any other members have any other
questions
representative scitec
representative mcguire this does not
expand authority or change scope of
practice or anything like this is
basically an enhanced
uh house clean housekeeping well that
does clarify
the ways that one can show one's
competence in
acupuncture
but it doesn't change the scope of
any other members have any other
seeing none we thank you for your
testimony
are there any other members from the
by any chance do you have a pink card
you you may
give your testimony and then when you're
finished if you could please fill out
if you could push push thank you very
much thank you for taking my testimony
i'm elizabeth rob i'm a licensed
acupuncturist and i'm here in support of
hb 1192 and i want to thank chairwoman
mcguire and representative schmidt for
being sponsors
this bill seems to reflect a national
trend of removing obstacles for
professional licensure which
the bill
puts term limits on licensing board
members which we should have just like
any other licensing board
and also one of my main concerns is
removing the requirement that
acupuncturists must maintain active
status with the national certification
commission of acupuncture and oriental
medicine taking the test is one thing or
an equivalent but we shouldn't have to
be required to continuously pay for the
active status
last summer i spoke to the federal trade
commission about the anti-competitive
practices of the ncc aom and many other
acupuncturists have done the same
i brought some of the financials for ncc
aom
in 2019 their chief operating officer
finally retired cory ward cook her
outgoing salary was a quarter of a
million dollars
they maintain an office on k street
they're a certification commission but
they also have a lobbyist they lobby for
policies that benefit their own
certification organization
not licensed acupuncturists as a
profession
their tests are very expensive
it costs four hundred dollars to apply
to take the test it's nine hundred
dollars to take all the tests and then
it's an additional five 500 to just pay
for like your first four years of
active certification which you maintain
with continuing education credits that
they approve
um
[Music]
so i was initially licensed in the state
of north carolina so i needed the test
but i didn't need to pay for the active
status in north carolina and i paid for
it anyway because the ncc aom promotes
their certification as a passport to
get licensure in other states and that's
not true i couldn't just take my
acupuncture school transcripts and then
my
national certification with ncc aom and
get a new hampshire license i wasn't
granted reciprocity here i had to start
from scratch and fill out an entire
application and i met
all the criteria
to get
a license to practice acupuncture in the
state of new hampshire so
what this bill intends to do is to make
i'll just say i support apprenticeships
for acupuncture
apprenticeships are making a comeback in
a wide variety of professions especially
in the health field behavioral health
field
students come out of acupuncture school
with a hundred and fifty thousand to two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
debt yeah yes they do with very very few
job prospects
um
and we need to think about future
generations of acupuncturists that's why
we really need to reinstate the
acupuncture apprenticeship route
and i'm just going to add two more
points um
in our statute currently we have the
accreditation commission of acupuncture
and oriental medicine mentioned by name
they are the accreditation commission
that
accredits our acupuncture schools and
last fall they changed their name to the
accreditation commission of acupuncture
and herbal medicine so lawmakers around
the country are now just going back and
just making that name change in their
laws
and
my last point is about supervision for
acupuncture detoxification specialists
you think i should take my mask off
representative schmidt
okay
so does everyone know what an
acupuncture detoxification specialist is
okay um some members of this committee
are very familiar with it so i'm a
licensed acupuncturist i went to school
for four years i can needle points all
over the body but in new hampshire and
roughly half of other states in this
country we have another certification an
acupuncture detoxification specialist
takes a shorter course of training
they're trained in five acupuncture
points in the outer ear by the national
acupuncture detoxification association
or equivalent training and
that treatment is a support for
substance use disorder behavioral health
mental health stress anxiety trauma
and
so what i would say in terms of
supervision is i support widening who
can supervise to doctors and osteopaths
i'm one of two licensed acupuncturists
in new hampshire who has taken the nada
training that makes us eligible to
provide general supervision for
the adss
and
there are very few acupuncturists in new
hampshire who've taken the nada training
that's what they need to have in order
to provide general supervision
so yes i support widening who who can
supervise
i i would add that supervision is most
important in the first year any year
after that the adss know what they're
doing
um it just seems like a redundant let me
back up in 2017 that's when the ads law
was passed and acupuncturists pushed for
more supervision requirements than what
we have now and they did it because they
thought it would give them jobs which it
doesn't
we supervise as volunteers because no
one's making money practicing ear
acupuncture it doesn't earn them more
money at their jobs in programs or in
their private practices as behavioral
health specialists
and
they wanted more supervision over ads
because they thought it would be a form
of control
and i supervise as a volunteer because
i'm trying to get services to people
we've had an opioid epidemic for a long
time in the state of new hampshire i was
providing trying to provide another
resource for people and we have a
behavioral health epidemic i mean half
the people who are going to the
hospitals in new hampshire right now are
seeking behavioral health treatment
so um
you know i support you know lightening
up on the supervision for the ads's
they're competently trained and after
the first year they know what they're
doing so does anyone have any questions
representative lekis
thank you thank you for taking my
question so on uh page two
uh lines nine through thirteen you you
mentioned that uh the name of the
uh outfit that um
that certifies the schools
the name change the one that's in the
law here is aca om is that what it
should ncc aom gives the certification
exam for acupuncturists
acom yes a-c-a-o-m correct they changed
their name but it is a-c-a-o-m that sort
of it says here uh who has earned a
doctoral degree in the practice of
acupuncture from an a-c-a-o-m
or border-proof program so that's
correct correct and their new name as of
the fall is the acupuncture this is the
accreditation commission of acupuncture
and herbal medicine so would that
acronym change
that acronym would change and what would
follow up if i could
what would the new acronym be it would
be the a c a hm
c
a h m
does any other members have any
any questions
representative bailey just just along
those lines would the ncc aom become the
ncca hm no they're separate
organizations
you're going to send up a pink card
correct um i'm going to do that now okay
thank you are you on the board i'm not
see no further questions you thank you
so i have letters um who should i give
these to
you
thank you
are there any other members from the
i've been waiting so long to be here for
this
so this is thrilling
um i want to point out the word oriental
is considered a slur so probably the ncc
aom will change its name shortly it's
being taken out of all laws it appears
in our rules i have suggested to the
board they removed that but they have
not removed it yet
that's
yeah okay so my name is laura cooley i
live in orford new hampshire i'm a
licensed acupuncturist i'm a registered
not a trainer that's the national
acupuncture detoxification association
i'm the person who trains the acute
detox specialist that me and elizabeth
supervise
um and i'm an advocate for legislature
that improves
restrictions that are not helpful to the
public
um into practice which have only
increased over the 30 years i've been an
acupuncturist so the first thing that
this bill addresses is term limits the
board members have no term limits and
some members served for 20 years so
that's
this hb 1192 it imposes term limits
and coming that comes into line with all
the other oplc boards when i ask the
lawyer for the state there's no other
board that doesn't have term limits
um
our current law says you have to have a
current active certification by nccum
there are they are both our board
testing agency and a trade organization
that lobbies to create higher standards
at this point nccm is the sole route of
licensure and what i just heard i'm a
little confused because we were asking
to strike that as the sole route to
licensure to add apprenticeship but the
discussion that i just heard sounds like
you're requiring an apprenticeship to
also be certified by one of those
three options
and
that's the nccm does not accept them
anymore
so
you're not going to be able to get an
nccm certification and at this moment
there is no other certification there is
a california test they would not be able
to take that certification either so if
we don't remove that requirement we are
going to be we're not going to make any
progress here on this
um the nccm it tests just one style of
asian medicine there are many other
styles like korean there's a korean
college in pennsylvania they are not
able to practice in new hampshire unless
they learn the traditional chinese style
that this tests for there are many
different styles every country it goes
to they develop a different style people
from other countries cannot practice in
in new hampshire unless they take that
national test and you know that's a
three-year school to learn that style
um current nccm certification it's
required to to renew my license by rule
so in addition to licensing fees we got
to pay them dues as well so we are
double taxed essentially for our
licenses in new hampshire i don't
believe that is
that is um how it should be
mds they take their national boards they
don't pay them for the rest of their
life to have a license in a state
so hb 11 1992 it strikes that
requirement
no one will be damaged by this it just
takes money out of our pocketbooks
and it makes new hampshire a much more
attractive place for acupuncturists to
move because we do know of acupunctures
that will not move to a new hampshire
right now because of how difficult our
law is
and when it comes to apprenticeship i
became an acupuncturist through
apprenticeship i sat for the national
exam i passed the exam it's the
traditional way you you
learn acupuncture in many asian
countries
but the nccm it removed apprenticeship
as a route
to licensure
you can't sit for the exam anymore and
this blocks you from licensure in new
hampshire and many other states
so it's another reason i object to
paying those fees because that's how i
got here and they have eliminated that
there's various levels of acupuncture
training around the world in every every
culture there are ear acupuncture and
and more um
discrete services right discrete kind of
ways to treat with people with
acupuncture that does not require a
three-year education
when i contacted the nccm about why they
eliminated apprenticeships i asked them
for their board meeting minutes and they
said no we won't give them to you and
they gave me a link to their
board policy guide which says if you
have disgruntled memberships do not
provide transparency so
you can't get their meeting minutes they
won't give them to you when i asked them
why they did it they said the states
eliminated it themselves
and so that means that if i want to
change this policy i'm going to have to
go to all the states convince them to
reinstate apprenticeships and then
convince the nccm to do that
so
i find that a little burdensome
and i really hope that you consider
reversing this course
and you have put an apprenticeship
so i'm really grateful for that
um
so another issue is if i could back up a
little our law actually gives the
acupuncture board the authority to set
standards for education
licensing boards are typically charged
with protecting the public
um but
i don't believe this is usual practice
the medical board does not tell a
surgeon what college he needs to
graduate from and he does not tell him
what training they need to take in order
to do brain surgery
right
they take their the educational
standards are set by the accreditation
institutions they take board exams and
they passed
right that's why they practice medicine
so new hampshire adopted the nccm
requirements for ceus
that's supposed to keep you up in the
field protect the public so for my
required ceus last year i took a course
from their website a class called
introduction to astrology for the tcm
clinician
i failed to see how this protects the
public
uh in that class i learned that there
are wounds that can never ever be healed
and that patients that have difficulties
have chosen those difficulties for
themselves
i find these notions damaging
um
yet this is the standard the licensing
board has chosen for us
and again i took it right from their
and furthermore they have the right to
impose further regulations so when the
board created standards they took
language from massachusetts that very
language caused me to take a year and a
half to get licensed after practicing
for 10 years in another state without
complaint
even though i passed it the first time
13 years before they made me take
anatomy and physiology one again which i
did from a teacher they pulled out of
very long retirement and we used a 13
year old
textbook to do that which is when i took
it the first time
i could have been practicing along the
first buprenorphine doctor in new
hampshire in new england for this is for
treatment for opiate addiction
he gave me a room in his clinic but for
a year and a half i could not practice
and so
no income for a year and a half it cost
me 1700 to get licensed here through
that process
the board sent me a letter of apology
but that doesn't pay the rent i'd rather
have better policy
so um please reconsider the authority to
create standards in a law for a board
that by default endorses astrology
classes
as a way to protect the public
they haven't been allowed under the
banner these don't meet our new
hampshire standards
so reciprocity has been unavailable to
licensed acupuncturists from 28
different states under that banner and
are we really to believe that 17 000
acupuncturists in just five of those
states are so unsafe they can't practice
in that in new hampshire but they can in
those states because we're talking about
massachusetts
so um i'd ask you to support senator
guida's current bill sb 330 about
reciprocity as that gives authority to
the executive director to establish to
have a voice in establishing those
standards which at this point she
doesn't i have a lot of reasons to have
confidence in lindsay courtney her
momentum in trying to eliminate delays
in licensure and board
difficulties has been really great as
far as i can tell she's doing a great
job she had an audit conducted on behalf
of oplc that revealed the laidac board
to have all the same issues our
acupuncture board has with our law with
the rules and with board function
um i asked for a board review but i'm
told we can't get one because it's just
too minor and unimportant
um this support the report that she got
from the audit suggests apprenticeship
as a way to bring back
work to deal with our workforce shortage
and get rid of excessive delays in
licensing so thank you again
and less didactic training less
experience more online training with
competency-based assessments new mexico
has a excellent competition
competency-based assessment of
practitioners we could replicate that
and then when it comes to the
supervision
of adss
mds and do's are perfectly suited to
supervise this is totally safe
they supervise all 900 michigan trainees
they do so in other states so
if you use safe needling techniques
about the worst thing that happens is a
faint and i'm telling you in 30 years
i've trained over 700 people i made 11
trips to louisiana after katrina and the
golf spill i have never seen a person
faint i've witnessed 10 i've given
thousands and thousands of treatments
so this is safe so as elizabeth said
right now we are the only ones
supervising 40 ads's we're supposed to
make contact twice a year do you know
what it's like catching up 80 times with
people in this state who are busy in a
crisis
we've done it all for free
um i don't know of any adss that are
charged for this treatment
uh they if the job if their job will let
them they do it but they do it as part
of their work
so we're just asking you we're not
asking you for money we just want to
eliminate limitations and expand
services for all of our citizens
and i will end with a quote from dr
kenneth ryland who went to china with
president nixon
he says i am convinced that acupuncture
is going to be one of the greatest
contributions that any group of people
has made to the future of all medicine
if it is handled correctly by the people
of the western world
i know it works i saw it work
i'm just here to say we have not handled
it well
we have eliminated our public from being
able to access these services
um
our profession has created more and more
required education
when there's many tiers of training that
exist
they're there and there's distinct micro
systems like the ear
those are easily used by most people
and
acupuncture is far less regulated in
europe and in asia
so
please pass 1192.
thank you so much for your patience
thank you
representative likas
yeah maybe i'm a little confused
it sounded like you had some complaints
about this bill and then you asked us to
pass it am i did i misunderstand well i
support this bill and the original
language i believed struck the
requirement for nccom as the only route
of licensure but the language that i
heard earlier today does not remove that
i mean are you follow up are you
speaking to the language i don't know if
you have the bill in front of you i
think there's a copy here
i do not but it was
the licensure i mean the
certification through nccom
the cali test right and another
potential you know we don't want to
close the door on potential
other potential certifications that can
come along
right it says after the kelly through
examination or credentials documentation
reviews see in 2
but then the language i heard discussed
today sounds like it does require a
certification
well i think the language if i follow up
if i may
um if you look at line um 26 on starting
in page two
and carrying into the next page
is the actual language i don't know
whether
discussion earlier accurately
reflects that but that's what the
that's
line 26 is striking the language around
ceus
on page two
line 26 that i'm looking at strikes and
ccm certification continues to require
at least 30 professional development
activities
oh it's page before that sorry
yeah starting at line 29 i guess
right
that says
they'll give one you're going to be 21
you have to have an nccm certification
or equivalent certification or pass to
california
so that
that
requires
i guess my question is are you okay with
that language or or
or not i
the apprenticeship was in that list
somewhere
i mean this is saying you have to have a
yes i believe so right that i definitely
object to that okay thank you
um you know if people have graduated
from an accredited college
i don't object to them taking a
certification there's only one available
right now and the cali from california
so there's only two available right now
and i don't believe apprenticeships can
sit for the cali either
so if you're requiring that and an
apprenticeship it's not going to be able
to happen for apprenticeships
does any other members have any
questions
representative bailey
i i believe
we had heard earlier that there was
three
three paths here
and there's oars in between them
so she's objecting to the first one but
there are or this other path or this
other path if i understood all that
correctly
no
representative like us if you have
so as i understand it
a is 21 years or older and then
i mean each one of the like a b
c d
all have to be
met and azhb
is the certification you still have to
have
ncclm certification or equivalent
certification approved by the board or
successfully passed the california
license exam
um
and so that is a requirement b is a
requirement
another requirement is you pay the fee d
is i think what you're thinking of
you have a earned a baccalaureate
registered nurse or physician's
assistant degree from accredited
institution and has a valid current
license to practice
acupuncture from another state or but
then on line eight
all of that or but no that or is under d
it doesn't go back to the previous page
i see you know it's kind of like
parentheses and doing math or something
or has so either you have the
baccalaureate
um or
certain other degree of those types or
you've successfully completed a
post-secondary acupuncture college
program which is aca om or board
approved
or has completed a valid internship
program and it goes on about that so
to meet part d there are
three options
but you still need to have the according
to this the
certification from ncc aom or cali
or
are you comfortable with that
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you are there any other members
from the public that wish to testify
good afternoon again madam chair members
of the committee lindsay courtney
executive director oplc
oplc doesn't take a position on the
substance of
what's contained in this bill although i
will say that oplc
generally supports portability
and so provided that we can ensure that
minimum standards are satisfied through
other means we would support any method
to promote portability
i just wanted to
draw the committee's attention to the
similar fee issue that was discussed
previously on another bill it was page
two
line three
that would require the applicant to pay
the 110 dollar license fee
this
we're trying to eliminate statutory fees
for obvious reasons because we need to
change fees in order to
correspond with the cost allocation so
um i would suggest an amendment to
completely eliminate that
um statutory fee other than that i'd be
happy to answer any questions uh
regarding that or anything else that i
representative lekkas
i don't know if this is a a question
you'd want to answer but um
do you see a problem with eliminating on
line 29 on the first page
that whole
section b
so
i don't think that
that language is going to address uh the
concerns that you heard previously
the language in 2b requires that there
be a certification
and the testimony i heard previously was
that that constituted a barrier
to licensure in this state
the requirement that there be an
equivalent certification approved by the
board
the board doesn't issue certification so
unless there is an outside entity
that provided certifications they
wouldn't essentially the person would
have to have nccaom certification
and i would also know on page 2 line
i think 16
again oplc doesn't take a position but
generally speaking my observations are
that when you give a certain amount of
discretionary
authority that is listed here in line 17
that demonstrates a balanced approach of
clinical training and fundamental
sciences
that could be a cause for concern to the
extent that
i don't know what that means and it
would require the board to promulgate
rules
and
sometimes
there there can be
another opportunity to you know set high
barriers i'm not saying that this board
would do that here but that's another
opportunity i think that you know the
committee may want to consider
um actually creating
oplc very much likes concrete
requirements set forth in statute that
limits the ability of regulatory boards
to just come up with requirements
outside of the statutory construct
yeah my question actually was if you saw
a problem with
eliminating
item b starting on page one line 29. so
i can't i can't speak to that i um only
because uh
well i can speak to that i can say that
i fundamentally uh don't agree with
requiring a certification that can no
longer be obtained so to the extent that
that's
the requirement
i would eliminate the certification
requirement because that would certainly
impose barriers
thank you
um so what you just were remarking on
does that mean that you don't feel that
the board and olpc are in a position to
determine what would be
an acceptable intern program
that you want
you don't know of any
standards of certification i don't i
don't i don't even know what it would
look like so
yeah no i i can only speak for oplc i
can't speak for the board i'm sure the
board um would have opinions as to what
constitutes a balanced approach of
clinical training and fundamental
sciences
except whenever you have something that
requires a bit of discretion in there
it's an opportunity for disagreement
right so if the
if the concern here is eliminating
barriers
um
you know that would be an opportunity
for them to regulate
and impose certain requirements that are
not in statute we generally oplc
generally opposes
giving that amount of discretion to
licensing boards because
because it's not concrete it doesn't
allow us it doesn't provide for
objective
means for assessing minimum competency
but i'm sure that the board could come
up with what they determine as a
balanced approach of clinical training
and fundamental sciences
i guess the question is whether or not
the committee you know would want to
retain that authority for themselves
representative fellows recognized for
follow-up so
it seems to me the only way to
figure out which interim programs
would qualify would be for some
some entity if it's not the state of new
hampshire it would have to be some other
you know
association or whatever
that would certify
those programs by having visited them
and looked at their looked at their
curriculum or whatever
you can do in a number of ways
representative you can
for many of our practice acts
the requirements for the education are
set explicitly in statute
others
correspond with an accrediting body like
you heard earlier in the board of
medicine
others do provide the discretion to the
board to approve education programs and
determine so this is the third approach
i'm not saying it's a wrong approach i'm
just saying if there's a concern
regarding portability and barriers you
know the committee may want to consider
retaining that authority with the
legislature
but yeah you can mirror an accrediting
body or you can put the requirement the
representative lekas
thank you um
on the same section
would it i mean it already says that it
and which conforms to ncc aom standards
what if it just said
has completed a valid internship program
which conforms to nccaom standards and
left the rest out
someone's
i mean
i would read what what you just said as
not requiring um ncaa om certification
but just that that they have to come you
know they have to basically do
meet the same standards and it could be
a different program so
um
the thing is though i mean how long does
that program have to be
so i guess you would say or has
completed a valid internship program
three years minimum and which conforms
to nc caom standards
to me that would make much more sense um
because it would take uh you know
the discretion out of it so to speak to
some extent there's still always
discretion but it would eliminate that
balanced approach of clinical training
because i'm because what's going to
happen is there's going to be a long
discussion right about what's a balanced
approach and we're going to have to do
rulemaking and it's going to kick this
out
farther follow-up
recognized follow-up representation the
reason i i didn't include the three
years was that
yeah i don't know if the ncco standards
has a minimum amount of time but i mean
if the program meets the standards i
would think adding the three years would
be superfluous but
that's a valid point okay thank you
representative bailey
one of the points that was made was that
this
this particular nc whatever organization
they tended to favor a chinese school of
this
and but there was an alternate korean
school and maybe even others that
may be disadvantaged by using this is
uh licensing or regulatory or
whatever yeah do you have any
suggestions
i don't um just because i
my profession is not um acupuncture uh
oplc generally supports though um having
alternate methods of licensure and it
shouldn't just be one approach so
anything i think that comes out of this
committee we would we would support
having multiple different approaches and
not just the ncc aom standards
representative scitec as i listened to
all of this discussion i'm wondering why
and how this is mushroomed how come
somebody from the board is in here
i i can't speak to um
representative lekis
uh just uh chair mcguire are you
thinking of sending this to a
subcommittee
i was afraid i would get that when i
answered it so maybe
so maybe we can continue this uh
subcommittee
representative fellows just one tiny
question about how many people are
licensed in new hampshire to for
acupuncture i believe it's in the 150
range
and there's approximately 30
ads acupuncture i
but that's just based on memory
representative
thank you
are there any other questions from the
committee
thank you
seeing none miss courtney thank you for
your
representative schmidt did you have a
question
thank you madam chair uh so i refrained
from putting in the card initially
because as you can see i'm on the bill
but uh i'm very relieved to hear that
approving of the idea of having a
subcommittee and representative lekkis
has already asked a number of extremely
useful and valuable questions
and we shouldn't be tweaking the
language here on the fly
we should get it right
the first time
but the reality is that this
sub-specialty of acupuncture is a
valuable resource and when we had the
initial bill
what five years ago ms cooley
but um
it was a number of years ago
the acupuncture board initially
had some issues with regard to so-called
accu-detox in other words the specialty
that miss cooley and miss rob uh we're
talking about where the ear
the outer edge of the ear is
is
is put as treated with needles i've had
the
procedure myself
and it's
not painful
and
i didn't have any issues it was just an
offer to the legislature anybody who
wanted to participate to see what this
is all about
these two ladies miss rob and miss
cooley
are
the experts here in the state of new
hampshire on this issue but i've also
worked very closely
with
cindy through jetty who was the chair of
the acupuncture board was working very
closely
with
ms cooley with regard to
some of her training issues
and
this is a valuable service to people who
have some of these issues some of these
problems
so i'd like to see us get the language
right i'm very glad that representative
leckis
has asked all these questions and
and highlighted some of the issues that
we're all struggling with in terms of
getting the language exactly right but
but these are the ladies who are the
experts
you heard the passion in mrs cooley's
voice
and
and she has been doing this as i know
for some 30 years so uh
if we can have a subcommittee on this
i think we can iron out some of these
issues uh and make sure that we can go
forward as you i i i don't want to and
i don't want to interpret too much about
the fact that the acupuncture people are
not here but i do know that the chair is
uh miss cindy thoruggetti um is working
very accurately and cooperatively
with mrs cooley and miss rob
to try to expedite
this service to the citizens of new
i'll take any questions representative
lekkas i just want to say that um
i asked for the subcommittee uh meeting
to be on the uh
i think it's the the 20 friday the 28th
at 1 pm i haven't gotten confirmation
we've got that time but
if the people who are entrusted could
make that uh it would be helpful and
miss courtney if there's anybody from
the board who could make that that might
be
might be appropriate
thank you
so thank you very much colleagues and as
i say i'd really like to see us
fix the little tweaks in language it's
important to get a clarification and be
sure that we are doing what uh the
practitioners
know to be necessary
and to get rid of some of these ncaa a1
references in the statute
so that we can
for one thing the the the costs that are
being imposed by the existing statutes
for practitioners to have to
maintain
all these certificates and so forth on
an ongoing basis
is just
you know it's like having an endless
subscription
to an important to an expensive service
that you don't need anymore and you
don't want anymore that's not fair so
thank you very much i'll
submit a pink card
are there any questions for
are there any other members from the
public that wish to testify on house
seeing none we will close the hearing
we will meet back at one o'clock for
i'm opening the public hearing on house
bill
1444 and i call on the prime sponsor
representative grota
thank you madam chair i'm jackie grota
and i represent rockingham district 24.
i was asked by oplc to file health bill
1444 and support its purpose
for those who are unfamiliar with
medispas
these are businesses that are growing
quickly as people face aging and find it
helpful
find a helpful treatment for the
qualities of their lives
whereas some of you may cut your hair at
home or go to the barber
or go to a salon for a color and
manicure
there is a top of the pyramid care that
involves removal of wrinkles and jowls
and other part of the parts of the body
that are following the natural pull of
the earth
as you can imagine the price of these
treatments are notable and the margin is
healthy which results in the growth of
the market in populated areas
this is the field of the medispa and
there are 18 meta spas on the new
hampshire seas coast alone
but high-end salons are also extending
their reach into this market
this the aim of this bill is to lend
credibility to and safety to the market
thank you
i'll answer any questions if there are
any
thank you are there any questions by the
sponsor
for the spot for the sponsor
seeing none a representative scientific
exact would you mind saying you talked
about anti-wrinkles would you mind
elaborating a little bit what happens in
one of these places is this a botox
treatment plant
well it can be it can also be plastic
surgery but if you pla they also insert
thank you representative grota
yes
i hope i didn't mangle your name too
badly
good afternoon my name is zubin
bhatlibala
i'm a board-certified physician and i'm
licensed to practice medicine in the
state of new hampshire since 2003 i'm
also licensed to practice medicine in
the state of massachusetts
i completed a prelims surgery internship
at boston university and i've completed
my residency at tufts in boston
i have been the medical director of the
acute rehab unit at catholic medical
center for 18 years until it was closed
down for covid
i have also been the medical director of
hillsborough county nursing home in new
hampshire
i have also worked in a multi-specialty
spine practice in bedford new hampshire
i recognize the need for an organized
aesthetic practice in the state of new
hampshire around six years ago
in my travels to other states i noticed
that new hampshire lacked the cutting
edge technology that was available to
residents of other states when it came
to aesthetic medical procedures
about six years ago therefore i started
an aesthetic medical practice
which to the common layperson is now
known as a medical spa
we started out by having two physicians
and two nurses
today
our medical spa consists of two
physicians two four nurse practitioners
five registered nurses two estheticians
and three front desk personnel
in short in the last few years we have
grown and so has the need for aesthetic
procedures in the state of new hampshire
we have been instrumental in bringing
cutting edge technology such as cool
sculpting for body sculpting various
neurotoxin injections and various dermal
fillers
and also the best and latest laser
technology to the residents of new
hampshire
prior to that
a lot of our residents had to cross
state borders to try to get these
services which were not readily
available to them
some of the people testifying with me
today are basically the pioneers of the
aesthetic industry in the state of new
hampshire
our common goal is to make sure that we
bring the latest technology that's
available to everybody else in the
country
in a safe manner to new hampshire
i'm sure that there are a lot of people
in this room who are not aware of what a
medical spa really is
it is essentially an aesthetic medical
practice that is run very similar to any
other medical practice
patients fill out clinical medical
history forms
these are reviewed by physicians and
nurse practitioners
patients are then assessed by providers
and cleared for these treatments
these treatments are carried out by
registered licensed nurses nurse
practitioners physicians licensed
estheticians in the state of new
hampshire
all of our staff undergo extensive
training and supervision prior to
performing any of these procedures
we carry medical malpractice insurance
we follow all hipaa regulations we
document in patients chart using
electronic health records and
essentially treat the patient just as we
would in any other medical setting
please note that the insurance companies
are very stringent about who they insure
for medical malpractice
if it was felt that the practice was
conducting business in an unsafe and
unregulated manner they would not
provide malpractice insurance to these
practices
our staff are thoroughly trained before
providing any services whether they are
neurotoxins karma
fillers or lasers
some of this training is provided by the
vendors of the companies that provide
the products and equipment to us
in my medical practice i use an emg
nerve conduction machine
and i do not get any special training
from the state for that the training
that i've had earlier in my residency
and in my practice combined with the
vendors training is usually what
suffices
also
i do botox injections in my medical
practice for treating migraine headaches
cervical dystonia spasticity and other
medical issues
i am not mandated to have any specific
state training for those
procedures
i believe the same rules should apply to
a medical spa setting
i do not know of any instance where the
medical director of a medical spa was
not readily available when needed
i do not see the need for any direct
on-site supervision
from the medical director
i treat patients in various settings and
when i'm on call i get multiple calls
wherein a nurse assesses the patient and
provides me with the details and the
status of the patient based on that
information i have to make an informed
decision about
the
care
the nurse then carries out the order
that is given to them by the physician
i do not see why it should be any
different in an aesthetic medical
practice setting
i do not have to supervise a nurse on
site in a hospital setting when they are
administrating
iv antibiotics or iv blood products
based on my orders
today also the use of telehealth to
assess patients and treat patients is
acceptable and mainstream in the
practice of medicine
this too should be an accepted form of
communication and assessment of patients
in any setting including medical spas
i am not sure how many of you are aware
that the rules for medical aesthetic
practices vary from state to state
in the state of massachusetts a licensed
laser technician such as an aesthetician
can run a laser machine
but in the state of in the state of new
hampshire a laser machine can only be
run by a registered nurse a nurse
practitioner or a physician
it would be really easy for all of us to
open an aesthetic medical practice in
the state of massachusetts as it would
be more cost effective however our
common goal has been to make basic
aesthetic technology available to
residents of new hampshire in the safest
manner possible
any new unnecessary and stringent laws
would therefore make our residents drive
across state borders to massachusetts
vermont and maine to get basic aesthetic
procedures and
this would result in loss of revenue and
loss of jobs for the state of new
hampshire
as you all know in this difficult day
and age healthcare professionals as well
as various services and products are in
short supply
it would be an unnecessary burden to
further impose stricter regulations that
would harm the current aesthetic
industry in the state
it should be noted that there are
various other practices that are
offering cosmetic procedures and
non-cosmetic procedures under the same
medical practice
it is unclear if this legislation would
even target those established medical
practices from providing those
procedures on the side
i would also like to point out that this
legislation targets cosmetic medical
procedures which are really not well
defined
in a medical spa setting we take care of
various other medical issues also such
as acne scars weight management
hyperhidrosis
and various other medical issues
we are essentially improving the overall
physical and mental well-being of our
patients with these procedures
we have also started a non-profit
organization called the aesthetic
medical providers of new hampshire this
consists of physicians registered nurses
nurse practitioners physician assistants
and other providers
our goal is to make sure that the
aesthetic procedures in the state of new
hampshire are carried out in a safe
manner with adequate training this
non-profit organization will provide the
necessary resources that aesthetic
practices need
to operate safely in the state of new
hampshire
we want to make sure that
medical aesthetic practices and medical
spas are differentiated from hair salons
nail salons and any other spa like
businesses
we are essentially a medical grade
practice following all hipaa rules
conducting medical evaluation of
patients before treatment having signed
consents for all treatments documenting
in electronic medical records and
everything else that is done in a
medical practice setting
please note that all our staff are also
governed by our respective boards in the
state of new hampshire such as the board
of medicine the board of nursing etc
irrespective of whatever setting we're
practicing
having any other entity oversee or
practice would only mean over regulation
which i believe in this case is not
necessary
thank you for your testimony
will you take questions sure
representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking my question
my understanding
is that a person's medical insurance
will not cover any of the procedures
that are done at any of these medical
spas is that correct
for the most part
medical insurances will not cover these
procedures however
if
we
get a patient that is transitioning
a certain portion of their laser hair
removal is considered
medically necessary and this will be
covered by insurances which will be
reimbursed back to the patient
also if we are carrying out botox for
procedures such as migraine headaches
again the patient can get reimbursed
back from the insurance
thank you
jessica
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee my name is jessica
callapolidas i am the director for the
division of enforcement at the office of
professional licensure and certification
i am here on behalf of oplc today in
support of house bill 1444.
um i did submit written testimony so i'm
not going to
take much time i'll be brief
i did want to highlight a couple of
points
um this is seen as a necessary measure
to ensure the safety of the public
it would require the registration of
medical spas which that would allow us
to proactively
inspect those facilities
proactive inspection is important
currently we cannot investigate
unless there is a complaint filed at
that point the public has already been
harmed
the services procedures and treatments
that are provided at medical spas are
just that they are medical in nature
the fact that they are for purely
cosmetic reasons does not take away from
the fact that these are medical
procedures treatments and services that
are being provided
and they do require the proper oversight
training supervision and delegation by
the boards of medicine
nursing pharmacy and the board of
barbering cosmetology and aesthetics
have all provided letters in support
these are the boards that oversee the
various licensees that work in medical
spas
and they support this as a needed
measure
the medical spa industry is growing and
can be quite lucrative
this growing industry will benefit we
believe from this legislation as it will
increase consumer confidence
in these procedures and treatments being
received by consumers in new hampshire
it'll increase confidence that they are
being done safely
and by those medically qualified to
oversee and delegate them
the proactive inspections would also
increase consumer confidence
because again instead of waiting until a
complaint is filed when injury has
already occurred to investigate it would
allow us to go in
proactively
and to help assist
those facilities with correcting
anything that needs to be fixed to bring
the only other thing i will mention is
that in speaking with representative
merchant today
um an item was brought to our attention
and we will be seeking an amendment to
address that item that he he brought to
our attention
thank you representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
we heard in previous testimony
that
a majority of the procedures done at
these facilities is not covered by
insurance
now
if something goes wrong and there's no
oversight or your
board cannot get in there to investigate
make sure everything's run properly
then would it not be upon that
individual to seek
uh
some remedies to something that might
have been done wrong during the
procedure versus an insurance company
trying to recover those costs for that
individual wouldn't it come out of that
person's pocket to try and recoup if
something
had been done wrong and harm that
individual on a certain procedure
um i'm uncertain it may come down to
their malpractice insurance
or they may have civil
remedies i'm not certain follow
but it would be the individual patient's
obligation to foot the bill to
try and recoup whatever was done wrong
against that malpractice insurance
if
yes they would not go through
their if their insurance did not cover
it i don't believe that the insurance
company would assist them in recouping
that cost they could file a complaint
against the specific licensee if they're
aware of who that is
but medical spas there's many different
types of licensees and we've actually
have had complaints eventually filed by
what i would consider to be a very
sophisticated complainant who did not
understand that they could file a
complaint until much later in the
process
this i think helps clarify that they can
in fact file a complaint with our office
it would go before the board
if it was a doctor let's say who had
caused the harm it would go before the
board of medicine
the authority still rests with the
various boards of these licensees the
registration again the main purpose is
to allow us proactive inspections thank
you
thank you madam chair
i thank you for being here today so you
referenced in your testimony before
representative goldie's question that
you would be seeking an amendment can
you clarify what you're talking or what
your
procedure is with regard to that or
you have somebody who's going to be
offering an amendment or
what is the purpose of the statement
that you were seeking an amendment
um it was to just put the committee on
notice um again i've been speaking with
representative merchant
he
brought something forward regarding the
pharmaceuticals that we think should be
included
i don't know if i'm qualified to
explain the details in the specifics but
that's where that amendment will be
coming from i'll ask representative
merchant if he intends to test the story
okay
thank you representative scitec you have
a question
yes you said you're going to be
proactively looking inspecting these
places
uh previous testimony has been that this
is a medical establishment who do you
does oplc is it qualified do you inspect
doctor's offices
who would be
you know who who does that does anyone
so our pharmaceutical inspectors can
provide
certain providers
in regards to the pharmaceuticals
specifically
one of our pharmaceutical inspectors is
here and she'll testify i think she'll
be better able to explain what it is
that she's able to do in the limitations
but this would we would have to hire an
inspector who was qualified to do this
work they would go in it would be
similar to
barber shops and cosmetologists
estheticians
they have to file for shop licenses and
we can't inspect those we do inspect
them upon opening and then up to twice a
year after those are proactive
inspections to ensure that everybody
working there is properly licensed and
that they are compliant with all of the
rules um
of the board because that is it protects
the public by ensuring that all health
and sanitary
thank you representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman thank you for
to
kind of clarify
what representative scitec was just
asking so you're saying that
proactive inspection and you're saying
that
the board of cosmetology barbering etc
was all in favor of this bill so
if you could clarify for me my
understanding is the board of
cosmetology aesthetics barbering
individuals go to school to be trained
for that
and therefore
that particular board is following up
with
inspection so if these individuals are
not going to school for barbering
cosmetology aesthetics etc then why
would that be the
why would they be the ones following up
with
inspections of these facilities
if i understand your question i
apologize if i don't but if i understand
your question it would not be our
cosmetology inspectors who would be
conducting inspections of the medical
spas
it would we would hire an inspector who
was qualified
to inspect them
did that answer your question
what
what particular i guess practice is
going to be the ones that are going to
be inspecting
we would have to determine what those
qualifications are
um because there are so many different
licensee types it would have to be
somebody i think has a certain amount of
medical knowledge
possibly pharmaceutical knowledge in
order to properly inspect
but the job the job requirements and
classification would have to be
determined
so to follow up with that on line 20
where it says does not meaningfully
promote the proper function of the body
or prevent or treat illness or disease
i i think where my confusion is coming
in is i'm hearing
border cosmetology i'm hearing
aesthetics now i'm hearing
uh
possible medical practice or
pharmaceutical
but we also just heard that
insurance does not pay a friend of these
procedures so i guess i'm a little bit
confused on
are we staying in our own lane here or
is it just a
i guess just a mix of what you feel like
it should be
so these are medical cosmetic procedures
they are medical procedures treatments
and services that are provided for
i have a question
does the oplc and the board of medicine
inspect doctors offices or surgical
centers or
or
urgent care clinics
um our pharmac so the board of medicine
board of pharmacy
okay the board of medicine does not
inspect
the board of pharmacy their inspectors
may inspect providers
thank you that was all i wanted thank
you
are there any other questions
representative o'brien thank you madam
chairman uh chairwoman
i'm just a little bit confused you said
your division would do you send out
people and it sounds like the position
does not exist but does it not exist
somewhere else in state government i'm
trying to avoid a potential redundancy
of services
to my knowledge it does not exist in
state government state service somewhere
else okay thank you
thank you
any additional questions representatives
fellows thank you
um i don't see anything
in this bill maybe i'm missing it and
you can point it out to me but my
question has to do with is there any
kind of board that will oversee this or
at least an advisory board that knows
about
medspar operations
no you are not
you're correct that's not in this bill
it would be a registration with oplc
but if
things were found that needed to be
referred it would be referred to one of
the boards that currently has authority
over the licensees that work in medical
spas we're not looking to create an
so you're saying if the inspector went
in and found something that didn't seem
right it would
have to
they'd have to identify the person
who
is responsible for that and if it's a
physician it goes to the board of
medicine and if it's a nurse it goes to
the board of nursing
correct we are not looking to take
authority away from the boards
thank you representative
thank you madam chair
i believe in your earlier testimony you
stated
that
an inspector in the case of these
medical spas could only go in if the
complaint had been lodged and then
potentially that harm had already
occurred
my understanding is that
the cosmetology board and the other
boards that you supervise at oplc
can and do regularly inspect but on an
unannounced basis they can go in they
don't have to have a complaint lodge
so why the difference in
in the causation if you will or
authorization for an inspection with
this
type of facility
thank you for that question
um so
you're correct there are current
mechanical and you know electrical they
can all perform proactive inspections
which is what we're trying to bring here
to medical medical spas so cosmetology
for instance there may be an esthetician
who works at a medical spa but if they
don't have a shop license
then we don't we don't know that they're
there and we don't know that we can go
and inspect them if they do have a shop
license within the medical spa
then
our inspectors our cosmo inspectors are
limited to inspecting that shop within
the medical spa they cannot inspect the
remainder they're not qualified to
inspect
what the doctors are doing they're not
qualified to inspect the pharmaceuticals
and the other things they would be very
limited to that shop which may be a room
within the medical spa
thank you representative
thank you um
as i understood it you said that this
sort of uh
inspection is not done of doctor's
offices where they do a variety of
medical procedures i would assume that
if there's a complaint it's the
particular practitioner there
what's special about medical spas that
would require this whereas doctor's
the difference i think with the medical
spas is that because they're cosmetic
procedures they're cosmetic for cosmetic
reasons even though they are medical
we are seeing more and more people
who are getting into the med spa game we
are seeing more and more people who are
perhaps not qualified there is a greater
risk to the public
with what is occurring at medical spas
than there is at regular
doctor's offices if you will follow-up
um
i mean if they're doing medical
procedures at these spas
aren't they required to be licensed as
appropriate to whatever practice they're
they're doing
as would it be in a doctor's office
you're correct they should be
but they are not always
president goalie
thank you madam chair and just to follow
up on that line
would inspecting them be one way of
finding out that those that are there
practicing and doing the procedures are
correctly qualified to produce those
procedures and have the
certifications necessary yes
follow-up
and
as you just stated isn't it the job of
oplc
to
[Music]
make sure any registration license they
need to do is
in the best benefit of the public
yes
thank you and just one last question i
don't know if you can answer this or not
we've
heard from the doctor about how big the
practice is that he's been in and how
prolific this is becoming here in the
state of new hampshire
do you know how many facilities would
fit this definition currently in new
hampshire or how many are practicing
i do not have a specific number
i do not have that information i can
attempt to do some research and if if i
other questions representative scitec
this idea of inspections is interesting
shop the aesthetics cosmetology one of
these places do you ask to see their
licenses is that part of the inspection
okay they've got to show that they're
they're not only just clean floors but
they've got to show that they they're
the real thing
yes absolutely making sure that everyone
is properly licensed is part of the
inspection
representative road
thank you madam chair just
just one more question or
if this at these particular facilities
would the person that is performing this
this procedure
ever be writing any kind of prescription
to be filled
it's possible
yes
right seeing none thank you very much
thank you
good afternoon
my name is dr nicole chartel and i
represent the aesthetic medical
providers of new hampshire the
non-profit group voicing objection to
the proposed bill
to provide some background about myself
i graduated from the university of new
hampshire
with a degree in pre-naturopathic
medicine which i developed with the
health management and policy department
i then earned my doctorate from the
southwest college of naturopathic
medicine and health sciences in 2008
passed all boards gained licensure to
practice medicine here in new hampshire
and i've been here for over a decade
i'm currently pursuing my fellowship in
aesthetic anti-aging
medical fellows are doctors who receive
further medical training
with within a sub-specialty so they can
become master practitioners within a
niche area of medicine
i'm the single member owner of
a medical practice and a medical spa
at the at the medical practice we
perform all of the injectables and
laser treatments and on the first floor
below us we do
massage and regular facials and things
like that
um
i have
to say that i feel that this is
definitely duplicative we are subject to
inspections
um randomly and
there are
in looking into things all of the boards
for the most part have some position
statement about
safety
the board of nursing
has a position statement already
stating that um the clinical practice
advisory regarding the role of nurses in
cosmetic services
that there's
that their delegated skills performed
under the supervision of a physician or
an aprn and training and competency
requirements are already listed under
nursing 405.01 pertaining to these
services their statement even goes on to
explain that a medical provider should
be available to the nurse
for supervision in person or by
telecommunication methods and must be
available within four hours of the
treatment
physicians assistant board also has a
published statement on safety regarding
cosmetic procedures the cosmetology
board is very clear that aesthetics and
massage therapists cannot do medical spa
treatments puncture the skin injections
or anything like that
so
i think if there is a safety concern it
should be brought to the boards and say
here are some safety perimeters and
let's you know can you update your your
position statement on this and give your
licensees some best practice guidelines
i don't feel that we need to have a
whole nother regulatory board another
fee for our med spas right now we're
already recovering from covid
we don't need to you know have all these
additional inspections
we
answer to our boards we have to practice
medicine ethically
and
if someone is doing medicine without a
license there are ramifications for that
already in place
jail being one of them so you know that
so um
you know i definitely think that
this is over regulation duplication of
existing regulatory boards
and
you know i just i don't think any of us
thank you for your testimony
representative will you answer some
questions
will you answer some questions yes
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here to testify and answer my
questions
um you stated that you
are already in
receiving inspections could you tell me
if that's in the medical spa portion of
your facility and who and how often does
that inspection um so
our board had asked
us to sign up for voluntary inspections
and so some of my colleagues have
already been inspected there was no
you know there wasn't anything that
happened
and i think boards can ask that if you
know within the guidelines that they put
out for best practices too
but um
we have the board of cosmetology come in
and inspect
the first floor and then upstairs where
i perform the medical procedures board
of pharmacy could come in any time
unannounced
thank you but do do you have a
the board of medicine or the board of
naturopathic medicine come in
uh no i mean
and if something was going on at a
medical spa that wasn't right someone
would have to stand around there all day
and watch for an unauthorized person to
inject you know what i mean i don't
think that
that something that is really
even
you know it's i don't think that that
standard like no one comes in when i'm
having a regular office visit with a
patient and inspects there's nothing to
inspect really
unless you know you're
injecting pharmaceuticals and then i
think that that's appropriate for the
board of pharmacy to come in
follow up
thank you madam chair and so just to
clarify
the medical spa portion on your second
floor the only one that may come in and
inspect would be the board of pharmacy
uh well
unless i have the estheticians
performing facials upstairs and then i
would have their license clearly
displayed because everybody's required
to display lice licenses
and i would have to have a shop license
there
and do that
so
be the board of cosmetology but it's not
an inspection
it would also be an inspection if i had
estheticians
on the medical floor
so my situation is a little unique but
the point is that you know there are
boards to regulate these things already
and maybe they just need a little
assistance
updating
if if you feel that there is a safety
issue
then i feel like that should be brought
to their respective boards to help guide
representative
thank you
you are talking about uh
the state inspector or
or one of the uh
employees who inspect that
um
i'm sorry no no i'm trying to to
to to know if
this you bring the state inspector there
to inspect or somebody else or regular
so i think it someone mentioned earlier
medical offices
probably wouldn't have a reason to be
inspected other than the board of
pharmacy
um
unless yeah i can't think of any other
reason why
you know issues that come up typically
aren't you know
injectables or pharmaceuticals
so
other ques other questions
seeing
representative schmidt
so so what it did maybe perhaps you've
already said this and i overlooked it or
missed it what is your connection with
the
entity you work for
i'm the owner the owner and
yes i have
four other licensed medical doctors one
nurse practitioner and two registered
nurses and a total of 20 employees some
of them being massage therapists and
estheticians between the two companies
so
thank you so so you are the owner but
are you also the director of the
operation yes i am owner i am director
yes thank you other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
thank you madam chair
women
i'm not here to support or to pose the
bill
i'm here to provide some clarification
to the board
to this committee
i am representative gary merchant for
the record
representing sullivan county
district 4. i'm here to speak on behalf
of myself
and also
i was the president of the board for two
years
on the board for 10 years
and i just wanted to provide some
clarification to the board here to
answer some of your questions
in regards to the inspections
the board of pharmacy
this has been a hotly contested
situation
between ourselves and the board of
medicine
the board of pharmacy goes in to inspect
for the safe storage and handling of
pharmaceuticals
it does not
repeat it does not
inspect for aseptic technique how the
drug is prepared
nor does it inspect for the
administration of the product
this committee has been through that
process before and has clearly come down
and saying that that's not
what i wanted to also
say to you folks
one of the things in the bill although i
think the intent is there
i did offer to work with the
sponsor of the bill and also those who
are working with the sponsor on the bill
to provide language to the clarification
to it
one of the things that we may want to
consider
in the amendment
the reason why people don't open a
pharmacy without a license is because
nobody will ship to the location unless
they have a license
so one of the things to try to do is to
amend the bill
to insist that the license has to be
there and allow the people who ship
products which are the wholesalers
are on the hook if you will for sending
a product to an unlicensed facility
it's just gives them an opportunity to
do this so that's kind of what i was
trying to accomplish through the
discussion with people before
and talking about an amendment
if there's any other things you folks
like me to try to clarify
based on my limited knowledge be more
than glad to help
thank you representative merchant are
good afternoon madam chair and
representatives my name is dr tanya
lawson
i'm a graduate of the university of
ottawa and the canadian college of
naturopathic medicine
i've been a licensed naturopathic doctor
since 2006
and licensed in new hampshire since 2015
and proud to call it my home
i'm an active volunteer in my community
and currently serve on the medical
reserve corps covid response team
i have practiced
medical aesthetics for 13 of my 15 years
in practice
i currently own and operate and serve as
medical director to a medical practice
in londonderry called in bloom health
and medispa
i offer both cosmetic and medical
treatments in my practice
i am a small woman-owned business and
have seven employees
i've had the privilege of winning best
doctor award in my community for the
past two years
my practice has completed thousands of
patient visits per year
i am also here representing medical
aesthetic providers of new hampshire
a non-profit group of providers that
spans multiple medical professions
and includes physicians naturopathic
doctors nurse practitioners
dentists nurses and physician assistants
our group is focused on creating best
practices in the industry and advocates
for providers in the field of aesthetic
medicine
i am here today to oppose this bill
this bill is fraught with errors and
misunderstandings about the industry and
about medical practice
many of you
may have not have been aware of what a
medical spa was
before hearing this bill
medical spas are medical practices
this bill begins with the premise that
medical spas are not regulated
indeed we are
every medical procedure i perform in my
office
whether cosmetic or otherwise
is regulated by my medical board
whether i'm performing a cosmetic botox
treatment or performing a non-cosmetic
treatment
my assessment of the patient
diagnosis
informed consent
treatment and documentation of the
encounter is the same
the same is true for the other regulated
professions practicing aesthetic
medicine such as physicians nurse
practitioners
etc
i would also argue there are many
services in a medical spa that are not
cosmetic in nature
for example my colleague has already
spoke about botox for migraine headaches
tmj hyperhidrosis
other medical spas offer services that
involve weight loss sexual wellness and
many others
i've spent
over a hundred thousand dollars in
additional training in aesthetic
medicine
it is common place for doctors to
complete training for in-office
procedures
with or without devices after medical
school
for example lasers are used in various
fields in addition to aesthetic medicine
specific injection training or drug
administration may also be learned after
medical school especially as new
treatments become approved
these procedures and devices do not
warrant having a separate regulatory
board
it appears that this industry
has been singled out while other
sub-specialties
perhaps those with more inherent risks
to patients
have not
it's also important to note that
malpractice insurance will not cover
procedures in which you are not
new hampshire has a high
safety record of aesthetic procedures
it has actually been impossible to find
public record of incidents that suggest
otherwise
in fact medical aesthetic practices must
build their businesses on reputation
safety and results
i'm also confused as to the timing of
this bill since so many small businesses
have already suffered as a result of
kovid
this law also goes beyond the proactive
inspection
passing this law would make new
hampshire one of the most regulated
states to practice aesthetic medicine
on par with california and new york
it would take our patients to
neighboring states where treatments
would inevitably cost less
this would pose additional risks to
patients since their provider would not
be close should an urgent concern arise
it would also reduce jobs in the state
and lastly it would disproportionately
affect women
since the majority of many spa owners in
the state are women
i believe this bill was created through
a lack of information and perhaps
misinformation about the industry in new
hampshire
in fact we were able to locate a very
similar version of this bill on the
american dermatology association's
website and we understand that this
national organization is pushing this
type of legislation nationwide in order
to take back the cash business that
these treatments create
passing this legislation will drive
business to neighboring states at the
cost of new hampshire patients and
taxpayers i am urging you to consider
thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair so you're clearly
reading us a prepared statement it can
you
since you're making a number of
allegations about this legislation
which i'm not a sponsor of so i'm
neutral on the whole issue can you
provide us with a copy of your testimony
yeah if my government relations team
advises me of such i will be happy to
okay well you're you're being recorded
so yes and i know um
did we provide them with the package
okay yes they will provide that
is public so yes that's fine okay
yes that's it'll just save us from
misinterpreting it sure
are there any other questions
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question i've heard numerous
times
in testimony that
over here man
oh sorry there is a
individuals wouldn't get medical
malpractice if they didn't do something
correctly
is there a requirement to open up a med
spa to have malpractice insurance
i don't think any provider would be able
to
practice without medical
malpractice in the state
follow-up senator goalie since we don't
have any regulations on medical spas
there can't be such a requirement
unless it's from the board of medicine
and that's what i'm trying is their
requirement because we've heard they
would not be insured if they did
something wrong but if it's not a
requirement
then there's no protection
so if someone was to file a claim
and you didn't have medical malpractice
you as an individual would be
responsible
but i can't speak as to what the
requirements would be for all the boards
in terms of
malpractice insurance i've just never
heard of someone wanting to practice
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair doctor thank you
for taking my question
uh in your testimony you mentioned there
would be some financial burden if this
bill would go through
uh other than the malpractice can you
explain what some of those
what would be burdensome i think
whenever we have additional regulation
and compliance issues that drives our
practice costs up
when our practice costs
increase then unfortunately that
translates to increased costs for
patients
so if we're competing
like me i'm in a town that's close to
the border there's nothing to say that
patients wouldn't travel
to a neighboring state to receive
services at a more competitive price
point
i do think
you know that's that's a consideration
anytime we have additional regulations
thank you
representative fellows
can you tell me what kind of regulation
exists in massachusetts because we've
heard several people say that you know
they would
move to massachusetts or it would be
cheaper to practice in massachusetts um
we can provide that for you if i believe
our government relations team did a
summary of the neighborhood the laws in
the neighboring states if you would like
us to thank you that would be very
helpful okay perfect so you could just
email it to the committee
other questions
thank you very much okay thank you very
much and we eagerly await that data
good afternoon my name is elsa croto i
am a pharmacy compliant inspector for
oplc
i am here to offer my testimony in
support of house bill 1444 regarding
registration of med spas for new
hampshire statue rsa 318 a
new hampshire providers are subjected to
a routine inspection performed by the
new hampshire water pharmacy inspector
where legend drugs are involved for
labeling storage safety and proper
disposal of drugs
through this routine inspection at
messpars my colleagues and i discovered
some very alarming unsafe practices that
would that could potentially cause harm
to our patients
most of you have heard of botox
it comes in two indications one for
medical therapeutic use and one for
cosmetic use
botox cosmetic is a neurotoxin
used to treat wrinkles crow's feet etc
it is an fda approved drugs
for a single dose vial which have no
preservative
it can only be used for one patient at
one time within one hour and discard the
remaining however at most of these
facilities it is being used as a
multi-dose vial for multi-dose pace for
multiple
for multiple patients
for multiple days
or weeks or until it is gone
this poses a great risk for
contamination and can have deadly
consequences in the eye of infectious
disease according to the cdc
we also found iv hydration such as
vitamins amino acid peptide drip being
offered to patients at medspa as well
there were little to no documentations
on current training by the medical staff
consistent consisting of mostly lpn
which is a licensed nurse practitioner
or
rn which is a licensed registered nurse
on administration of botox
no training on aseptic technique hand
hygiene when handling iv admixture
evidence every medication should be
stored at a recommended temperature by
the manufacturer however whether it is
at room temperature in refrigeration or
frozen and should be monitored and
tracked regularly
if the temperature is out of range even
for a small period of time this can
interfere with the integrity of the
medication
this practice was not in place at the
majority atmos
of mess bar that we inspected
there were no crash boxes containing at
least epipen
or benadryl available
at most of these facilities to be
administered
should there be an anaphylaxis event
that is when the patient have severe
i asked one of the provider that i
inspected
what would she do in this unfortunate
situation she replied quote i have to
use my son's epipen in my purse i guess
unquote
not only this is not only is this
illegal to use one specific one's
prescription on another in this case her
son is a minor that has a pediatric
pediatric strength of epipen
while her patient is an adult
the administration's
botox cosmetic and iv hydration are
mostly performed by lpn and rn and often
without any medical director presence
such as mdnd aprn to assist or supervise
while we are able to inspect the
provider themselves but often the
providers not own the mess bars
accountability needs to be in place for
both owner as well as providers and this
can be done through seeking licensure
from oplc this also gives us a broader
authority to expand our inspection to
ensure public safety
our patients place a great trust in our
healthcare system to protect them from
harm deliver the face the safest medical
practices
and have the best interest at heart
during every medical procedure we must
do everything we can to protect our
citizens and put their welfare above
cost thank you
thank you for your testimony
before representative schmidt raises his
hand could you we have a copy of your
written testimony please yes you are
and i also have a question
it sounds
as though you are actually currently
inspecting medical spas
as part of the board of pharmacy is that
correct
yes we only have the authority to
inspect the provider not the mess by
itself
the provider being the pharmacist no the
provider mean being meaning the the
doctor of the pln that are
thank you i quite understand thank you
representative schmidt you have a
different question
i i do is this going to a subcommittee
manager
yes i believe it will go to
representative pearsons but i'm not sure
about that
but it is going to sub committee thank
you
other questions representative fellow
thank you so based on your last response
is is it correct if i assume that
um all med spars are being um inspected
now for at least
um the pharmaceuticals because i'm
you know i'm thinking that they probably
all use botox right yes not all mess
bars so far we inspected some
that brought to our attention
and um but our
authority to inspect is very
limited we only can inspect for farmers
you know anything to do with drugs
that's my expertise
everything else
you know i don't have the authority or
so just follow up so you just have to
help me because i don't understand this
whole area all that well
so
[Music]
you
olpc
in specs or the board of medicine
whoever somebody board of pharmacy
inspects yes various medical facilities
to ensure that the drugs are handled
correctly as representative merchant
pointed out so does that mean that we
would want to add med spas to the list
we could because they are a
they they they are
doctors
facilities um
once we define them in statute otherwise
we don't have a number i believe that if
they're a medical facility run by a
doctor they ca that's one of the issues
that the board of medicine has with the
board of pharmacy
okay
thank you
can i answer to that question
so the board of pharmacy
our inspector only can inspect the
provider which is the nd the a the mdo
apin
pa
we do go out and inspect various doctors
offices
only inspecting the provider we don't
inspect the facility because they
understand you they do not hold a
thank you on seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank you
i know we're running over time so i will
try to be as brief as possible to all
committee chairs thank you so much for
allowing me the opportunity to speak
before you today my name is jennifer
fleming and i am a licensed nurse
practitioner who has been practicing for
the last 10 years both here in new
hampshire as well as massachusetts
my medical experience and expertise is
vast as i have worked in multiple
specialties including hospitalist
medicine emergency medicine and critical
care medicine
in addition to hospital-based practice i
was introduced to the field of aesthetic
medicine over five years ago and have
actively been pursuing my field in this
and have actively been pursuing my
passion in this field
i've worked for two separate practices
and will be opening my own medical
aesthetic practice within the next few
months
medical aesthetics as mentioned by
multiple other people today is a field
that is often misunderstood
i will kind of briefly we know that
medical aesthetics does not just perform
cosmetical procedures but multiple other
special
specialties as as everyone mentioned
including hormone supplementation
different devices medical weight loss
and it's really important to note that
we are not hair stylists or estheticians
we are
board certified medical practitioners
with very diverse medical backgrounds
who are credentialed to perform medical
procedures that fall within our scope of
practice
within the last year several medical
aesthetic providers here in new
hampshire including myself have joined
forces
to ensure that medical aesthetic has
appropriate representation here in new
hampshire and across all of our
respective medical boards
as leaders in the field of medical
aesthetics we have developed the
aesthetic medical providers of new
hampshire in an effort to promote
practice standards which ensure safe
patient-centered care
review evidence-based research
share updated laws and guidelines as
they pertain to aesthetic providers in
new hampshire and create a community
that encourages collaborative and
supportive efforts amongst its members
on behalf of our organization i would
like to share with you my concerns
regarding the integrity of this bill
as mentioned previously this bill
falsely identifies medical spas as the
only location where patients are seeking
out cosmetic procedures
multiple medical professionals and
specialties perform are performing these
same procedures in their office
including primary care offices
dermatology practices ent general
surgery women's health ob gyn office and
dental practices
so why were they not included in this
bill as well
the bill will also enforce our practices
to register mp fees which will fund the
specific
inspector to inspect us
however this does seem redundant as we
are subjective to review an
investigation by our boards if in fact
there was a something that needed to be
inspected
as well as the oplc
again it's unclear why we were then
focused when other
practices that are performing these same
procedures are not
asked to do the same
medical aesthetics
is not part of our initial didactic and
training in medicine or nursing practice
we see we must independently seek out
and pay for advanced training personally
i have traveled both nationally and
internationally for training and have
spent tens and tens of thousands of
dollars in doing so i have even brought
ultrasound to my practice as a way to
better assess vascular anatomy mitigate
risks and complications
assist with pro
proper diagnoses
and
deal with complications if in fact they
arise
i agree that medical providers need to
be adequately trained to perform any and
all procedures including medical
aesthetic procedures
however training in medical aesthetics
can come from multiple different forms
and prior to the bill determining what
is acceptable training this needs to be
understood and reviewed by our
respective medical boards
additionally this bill chose not to
include medical professionals including
physicians assistants and dentists
as well as it attempts to place
restrictions on medical professionals
preventing them from practicing to their
highest potential
next and most importantly this bill was
created without any deeper insight or
dialogue with medical aesthetic
providers here in new hampshire and did
not include our respective boards in the
process and did not seek to understand
the current issues in medical aesthetics
prior to proposing this bill
by no means do i sit here to refute the
need for guidelines and regulations in
medical practice medical aesthetics
included regulations and practice
guidelines are needed to protect
patients and to identify practice
standards that clinicians should and
must abide by
however regulation should not be
dictated to a profession that is already
regulated
and certainly without collectively
involving them in the process
on behalf of our organization i thank
you for your time and ask that the
committee opposed this bill
i would like to just quickly touch base
on
just to
give a little bit of overview as to some
of our other people that had just spoke
with regards to pharmacy and
the way in which
medication is used in medical aesthetics
i would be more than happy to provide
the board with probably an over 20 page
paper that i took the time to write to
investigate the way in which
not only medical aesthetic providers but
all medical providers use and administer
neurotoxins including botox that have
been
that has now become an exact an accepted
form of practice in medicine physicians
nurse practitioners providers we use
medications off label all the time
vaccines are used multi-use
and
i would like to argue that i feel that
it is basic learning in medicine that we
learn aseptic technique
so i don't think that we necessarily
need to have a different training for
this
i think that's all
that i have thank you very much
representative scitec would you mind
repeating what
the aesthetic medical providers of new
hampshire which is the organization we
created
okay that's straightforward enough other
questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right
in that case i'll close the hearing
and open the hearing on house bill 1429
thank you madam chair
i'm jackie grotta representing
rockingham 24 district 24.
oplc asked me to submit house bill 1429
regarding massage establishments
this committee has heard this bill heard
this bill in 2019
and passed the house but it was part of
the coveted cyclone when it reached the
senate
there was a concern at that time
regarding law enforcement in previous
hearings and we want to address this
today
this registration will allow oplc to do
its work in addressing victim needs and
educate businesses
so they can do their work in a safe
thank you representative are there
questions
yeah i this question applies really to
the other bill also
no i i
we license individuals and they're
subject to their scope of practice and
their
their boards their appropriate boards
how do you inspect an establishment what
do you do go in there the floor is dirty
i mean exactly what does
licensing and establishment mean as
opposed to the practitioners who are
working there
in this particular case it would be
establishing to make sure that
it would be
to ensure that the people that work
there have the proper licenses that
public health concerns are being
addressed
and that the business is doing what it's
supposed to be doing
safely
thank you purpose of goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
in a different statute don't we
license currently nursing homes and
other questions yeah i'm seeing none
that you can get up now representative
a good good afternoon my name is michael
porter i'm the investigations bureau
chief for the division of enforcement
office of professional licensure and
certification
i'm here to support house bill 1429
which does establish licensure licensure
for massage establishments i did email
late this morning a copy of
our proposed testimony so what i'll do
is put this aside i can leave a hard
copy here but i really want to highlight
what i call the critical features of
this particular legislation
first off under the current statutory
scheme
massage therapists require licensure but
the establishments hosting licensed
massage therapists do not
the structure proposed by this
legislation mirrors other establishments
requiring licensure just as
representative goley mentioned nursing
homes facilities
but also in the board of barbering
cosmetology
shops salons and booths the booth
they're independently owned
those are also licensed
by licensing any establishments in
accordance with the rules governing any
profession it provides a professional
licensing board the ability to inspect
primarily
and enforce proactively without waiting
for a consumer complaint to be filed
under current statutes governing massage
therapists oplc is only authorized to
investigate licensees
after a complaint has been filed
that generally means the consumer
already
believes they have been harmed
the proposed legislation primarily
ensures
that these these proactive inspections
will help will allow inspectors to have
flexibility to enter an establishment
for the purposes of a routine inspection
to ensure individuals are property
licensed
to perform professional services and
that basic health safety
standards are in place
one of the issues this bill also
addresses and it's it is an issue in
this state is the unlicensed practice
unlicensed activity is a primary concern
inasmuch as an unlicensed practitioner
has not even met the minimum
requirements for licensure set by any
particular board
including sanitation and health
requirements
unlicensed practice erodes consumer
confidence in the profession and harms
the reputation of those professionals
who have met the minimum standards
excuse me
by requiring establishment lights and we
do distinguish establishment from the
profession they are two separate
licenses
but by requiring establishment licensure
and authorizing unannounced inspections
of massage therapy establishments
inspectors will also be able to
determine if practitioners are properly
licensed and if not
oplc will have the authority to remedy
the situation in a proactive manner up
to and including emergency suspension of
the establishment license
i can give you a couple of examples
right now where we've had to intervene
on an emergency basis
recently we did shut down
two nail salons and while at first
glance people may not take that
seriously
here were the concerns it was an
independent random inspection on the
southern portion of our border here in
new hampshire
one shop had no licensed employees they
were open
they were conducting business we found
metal implements that still had dried
skin and blood on them i'm not trying to
be overly graphic but these are the
things our inspectors are finding out
there
and not one of these individuals was
licensed they did have a license for the
establishment
so we used 541a under the emergency uh
uh procedures act
well it's under 541 which is the
administrative procedures act but we
have the authority to emergently suspend
the establishment's license we did that
we
were able to work with the owner to not
only get those individuals licensed but
also worked with the owner of these
establishments to
fall into place as far as health and
safety concerns and sanitation
so we did we we suspended them
we also offer these licensees due
process rights licensees are entitled to
due process protections in this instance
they they were
mandated to have a hearing before the
licensure board within 10 working days
so this way if if the problems had been
fixed we could
reopen the shop and in these instances
it took about 30 to 45 days to get
everybody licensed make sure that the
health and safety standards were being
met
but ultimately the shops reopened our
goal is not to close businesses it is to
work with these
licensees but as you can see
you know
if we don't do have the ability to go in
and inspect the establishment we're
never going to find out whether people
are licensed or unlicensed and that is a
major issue as well as with massage
establishments
i want to talk a little bit about the
municipalities i have reached out and
in fact municipalities reached out to me
derry salem
and others and i believe some may be
here to testify today
these unlicensed establishments
and i say unlicensed
through the board itself
is a problem and i believe most of the
cities and towns have ordinances that
address them but they're not the same as
by creating the establishment licensure
procedure here we do provide
consumers with a predetermined agency
where reports of alleged misconduct
occurring in a shop or salon or
establishment may be filed and
investigated this allows for further
consumer confidence and right now we do
have a massage therapist board but as i
mentioned by the time we get the
complaint we can't investigate a
licensee until a complaint has been
filed whereas having an establishment
license we can go in proactively and we
can
do inspections uh and and we would base
it under the pharmaceut i'm sorry the
board of cosmetology which would be
minimum two two inspections per year in
some instances we only get to do one per
i do want to address the issue about law
enforcement and i know that there are
some that are worried about this being a
law this particular statute being used
as a law enforcement tool
the fact of the matter is many if not
most all boards and commissions under
oplc already have the authority to
report out to law enforcement
in fact
the case that i mentioned to you about
the nail salons
we were able to reach out to the
department of justice and one individual
the actual owner of the shop is being
prosecuted as are those who are
operating unlicensed we already have the
authority to reach out to law
enforcement so this statute doesn't
carve out anything special than what
we've already been doing with that
regard
it just allows us to go in and conduct
the proactive inspections this bill
would also allow us to
when we do conduct these inspections if
we do
spot evidence of any type of crime
we could reach out to the local health
department of the town we could reach
out to the local police department and
involve the new hampshire department of
justice
as as needed so i do want to just i
wanted to discuss that part of this bill
this is not adding additional law
i will tell you the inspectors that i
work with take great pride in the
education aspect of inspections there's
there's kind of a three-step process the
first is you want to educate if they're
minor violations you want to go in you
want to educate the owner or the
licensee and you want to help them
correct and remedy those situations
number two would be a disciplinary
situation where
health and sanitary violations for
example
if they're numerous we have to address
those not only through education but we
do
issue
violation points with board of
cosmetology for example
and they may be brought before our board
for a hearing at which time we will be
prosecuting them so there's a
three-layer approach but the first
so again i don't i don't want to be
repetitive
but we do support this
this particular bill for massage massage
establishments
again the licensees themselves are
licensed but the establishments are not
and this just provides another layer of
protection for consumer confidence
protection of the public health safety
and welfare but more importantly
this also benefits those licensees who
are who are working appropriately
and i'll take i'll be happy to take any
questions
thank you representative scitec
uh i have a couple of questions i'd like
to ask you but the first is
that had two aspects first you said you
went into a place uncer unlicensed and
uh
you were you made the case that you
tried to work with them they're now open
and
then i heard a little later it sounds
was it a different somebody else that's
been prosecuted
no there's there's there's a couple of
different layers so that in that
particular situation we worked with them
to once again open but that does not
prevent them from being criminally
prosecuted for their actions um our goal
was to ensure that if they were going to
reopen that they did so following the
laws and rules but that did not excuse
the criminality of their behavior
uh i certainly appreciate that that
you're this you're not the gestapo that
you're trying to work make this work
that's you i don't know but i want good
laws not necessarily good people my
question is this
uh there's something very inconsistent
here and i'm going to put this on the
table
there seems to be a a lesser
semi-medical sort of aspect that you go
in and you inspect and you look at those
but we don't go into dartmouth-hitchcock
we don't go into urgent cares who's
somehow they're too high class for that
sort of thing
right and where i'm going with this is
it's almost disingenuous to say oh we're
going to proactively do this nobody
complains going in and say hey doc i
don't think you're any good i'm going to
i'm hearing funny stuff and
i can i can clarify and hopefully this
will add some clarity
facilities and that's the term we use
for hospitals or long-term care
facilities are inspected under the
facilities division of department of
health and human services
that's a completely different
branch and different operation than we
have
so there are inspections that do take
place of hospitals uh long-term care
facilities and other medical providers
um but those are not ones that we
regulate and our boards don't have
that would be the equivalent on their
scale of the establishment license
correct
thank you are there other questions
representative bailey
thank you madam chair
um
i'm comparing
we we just
we just heard another establishment
licensing thing yes and i'm i'm a little
puzzled that this one seems to feel the
necessity to include
crimes of violence sexually related
why the difference between the two
well
it
i mean obviously those things wouldn't
be good in a medical spa either
no no sir but why do you feel like you
have to actually put it in statute that
this particular industry
has this problem
i i will tell you i mean i think that um
is that fair
i think i think it is fair and i can
tell you that
an unfortunate set of events does happen
in some some of these
massage establishments which does
involve human trafficking i am not an
expert on human trafficking i have
worked with the department of homeland
security i've worked with local police
departments to discuss
human trafficking but i certainly
and i think that would be a fair
question to bring them in at a
subcommittee level to discuss
but it's unfortunate fact in reality
that this does happen and i can tell you
from an enforcement approach was as it
pertains to human trafficking it is a
victim-centered approach
it is to help the victim first
and it's an unfortunate set of
circumstances but this does happen in
some of these establishments not all
thank you
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair uh you mentioned
in your testimony thank you sir for
taking my question but you mentioned in
your testimony uh working with the board
of health and everything
so this will
is my interpretation this bill will give
you more authority to do these than to
currently exist on the statute with the
border health now
in explain explaining it i come from
nashville we're very fortunate to have
that ford but that doesn't exist
statewide in that caliber
you're correct and and through the
pandemic uh the local the the board of
health in manchester for example nashua
other communities have been overwhelmed
with the pandemic
and that's not to say they're not doing
their job that they are
but this does add a layer where it's
more of a central repository
where through these proactive
inspections
if we can if we can find
issues earlier on we can make those
reports out to like i said law
enforcement or the health agencies that
would be addressed in the rule writing
process
and and it is really truly another it's
another tool for for municipalities to
are there other questions
yes representative judy yes thank you
madam chair
good afternoon sir
uh i'm just curious during the
inspection
what do you call minor violation
well that's a great question i think
it's probably
in the eyes of the beholder but
oftentimes
improper display of licensure let's say
in some shops you're required to
hang your license it may be instead
maybe in the back room instead of on on
the booth
it could be something as much as maybe
like in a cosmo inspection where they
hadn't sweeped up the hair from the
client before
i would say that those constitute minor
infractions the more major infractions
would be
not using what's called the autoclave
which is the
it's the unit to disinfect and to
sanitize
metal implements which are used to go
under the fingernails
if we find that those items have either
not
been properly sterilized
or there are still
bio potential biohazards on them that's
a major um
the foot spas
our inspectors go in and they actually
lift the cover off what you see on on
where you place your feet is nice and
tidy what you don't see is what's
covering the motor um and so our
inspectors do these are very detailed
sure
thank you mr porter and thank you ma'am
chair um
so uh we have been uh participating in a
little dance here of sorts uh so how
many uh towns are currently
afflicted with establishments which are
massage
establishments where there's no
well that's a great question i mean
nobody advertises criminality but
i can tell you it's affecting
from my experiences the southern
southeastern tier of new hampshire but
but i believe it's also encroached upon
the central
portion of new hampshire and i think
those members that are here from
municipalities can better answer that
question
okay
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you and i am available for
questions i put my telephone number on
my who who would like a copy of this
we'll take it thank you
and
we'll recycle it with our other papers
is there anyone else who wishes to
good afternoon my name is beverly
donovan i'm the economic development
director for the town of derry
mr porter has pretty much summarized
everything
that i think needs to be said in the
sense of
what the legislation is about
so what i would like to do is read the
letters that i have from different
departments
thank you we have received those letters
and we i believe everyone on the
committee can read so
just give us the highlights
um well
if that's the case then what i will do
is this will be a little bit off the
i heard some of the questions being
asked of
what maybe some of the more specific
issues are
i think what we're seeing is there's two
types of massage establishments
some that are relative to
like sports and rehab and medical issues
that people are having
after an injury those are more
therapeutic in nature the thing that
we're seeing a spike in
is on the side of
what
a lot of people would term spa massage
or just outright massage and and what we
are seeing is a lot of turnover
um in many cases less than a year where
new people will come in and say that
they're the owner
and the place will change hands in some
cases the landlords don't even know it
and with that comes a flurry of activity
around
our change of use forms in producing
secretary of state paperwork and id
and information relative to
the fire department's requirements on
emergency contact and that sort of thing
it takes a lot of time to get those
things straightened out
in some cases those establishments are
up and running in advertising before
they've even been
given their certificate of occupancy
in some cases where we've gone in to
deliver paperwork there is not a license
to be found
and if there is a license sometimes
there's no picture attached to it or the
picture looks different than the person
who is on the license
[Music]
this has been an issue there have been
instances in instances where
ice has come in to look at certain
establishments
and found that these there are people
living there
who shouldn't be and in some cases um in
a very unhealthy situation
we
are we're just seeing a lot of it and we
don't have any way of controlling it
without specific
complaints
and so we're really looking for house
bill 1429 to provide
some help in in the enforcement of
the rules of the professional licensure
especially as those people transition
into those shops
and to make sure that the people that
are opening these shops are the actual
licensed people that are working
within the shops
we do see advertisements i think i sent
somebody
to advertisements that i pulled up today
on the website
that show
they're very sexual in nature and they
have
headlines like new girls
sexy young girls i have that here i'm
happy to leave it with you
there are screenshots from today
of at least two of the ones that we're
dealing with in derry we need help
we can't do it without the state
stepping in
and helping us
thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
yes yes i see representative schuman i
was looking for someone who hasn't asked
so good afternoon mr donovan nice to
meet you in person uh so
uh
are we talking about establishments
where uh
trafficking is going on of employees and
illegal
activities are occurring in
under
behind locked doors
that is what we believe in at least five
of the locations
yes
thank you
other questions
so if i understand you correctly you're
asking for the state to help you come in
and enforce your local ordinances
so
the
we we've had
meetings with the state and with ice and
with our detectives and health
and code enforcement
and our problem is is if somebody
submits paperwork to the planning board
under our change of use we can't deny
them to open up a business so that's
step one
step two is
once we
sort of
know what's going on without a formal
complaint
there's no way for
for anybody to go in there and inspect
or to do a surprise visit there just is
no mechanism for that to happen
um
and and so that's been that stymies us
the only way so far that i'm aware of
that we have been able to go in was when
there were complaints
and i believe they were irs related
where ice came in
and had our code enforcement and
detectives go in on that scene and
what was found there was people living
in squalor
we would not have known that because we
can't go in and inspect and there is no
mechanism for
surprise inspection i guess you would
say or state inspection
so it's hard to correct those problems
thank you
are there any other questions from the
committee
representative fellows thank you can can
you just tell me a little more about the
planning
board approval would would they have to
obtain the establishment license before
they open up or would it be
they get planning board approval and
it's conditional upon upon them getting
a license how does that work
so the way it's set up for every
business right now is people fill out
the change of use paperwork and we
require
a certificate of good standing from the
secretary of state's office or
paperwork that shows that they have
indeed registered with the secretary of
state's office
and then for licensed professions we ask
that they
um for the owner or the manager whoever
is going to be the person in charge
and that's kind of where it stops once
once it's open
that person
may or may not be the one that's in
there
did i answer your question
you have a follow-up representing
fellows yeah so
the license they show you is is the like
the owner's license or the manager's
license and
because i'm just wondering how they get
a license for an establishment until
they're
there it's you know chicken and egg kind
of thing
well i would assume it's probably like a
hairdresser you can be licensed and
switch
places
you can go from one salon to another and
bring your license goes with you
it would be probably be the individual
license of the manager or person in
charge i would say
but i'll go a little bit further so this
might help
recently we had a licensed owner
that opened over here
and then all of a sudden that same
person did paperwork and they opened
over here and both were they were
claiming that they were the person who
would be the licensed person on site at
both
locations
that became a whole
paperwork trail and ended with somebody
or them
selling
their business to someone else
because
they were kind of forced to do that
thank you
thank you other questions
version of scitec
i'd like to follow up on the chair's
line of questioning and i want you to
know i'm going to take this very
seriously since you're a constituent
and that is this you said people living
in squalor
perhaps prostitution human trafficking
living in squalor that there are people
living in the retail space that violates
zoning
prostitution
human trafficking you don't need
licensing this is like getting al capone
for income tax evasion these are
criminal acts you don't need licensing
why don't the police go after this
after the fact those issues were
addressed but until
we were made aware and probably
bob mackie our code enforcement person
is here as well probably better able to
speak about that
but we can't do anything unless we're
once we are aware then yes steps are
taken and and that business did
sell to another person
that pretty much the very next week was
representative schuett mongolia
thank you madam chair uh
perhaps this is more properly addressed
to your enforcement person
but
would you not need probable cause before
you could
investigate whether there are people
please introduce yourself sir
good afternoon i'm bob mackey with the
dairy code enforcement office
so uh the question well probably
just to back up a little bit on what
beverly had said regarding and again our
process is unique to derry so different
towns have different
methods
with the town of derry when you come in
you are required as a new business any
new business fills out what's called
this change of use form
and then part of that is and that's with
the planning department and then what
they need to do is then provide
secretary of state information showing
that they're registered as a business in
the state
and then uh and so forth and then in the
case of uh
of the massage establishment typically
we're looking for that initial license
and so forth something to keep in mind
is the town of derry does not unlike
some towns like i believe salem we don't
have a separate
ordinance regulating massage
establishment
so as beverly had said once the initial
paperwork's generated that's complete
typically we do at that point code
enforcement and the fire prevention
office we go in we inspect we make sure
that you know things look okay from a
life safety standpoint
if everything looks okay at that point
we do it then we do issue a certificate
of occupancy
but again at that point
our authority pretty much ends because
we don't regulate them locally
and again without some sort of complaint
or cause we don't have the authority to
just go in on a routine and inspect
so that's why i think this legislation
would be critical so that if we could
get the shops licensed that way giving
the state
uh the ability to go in and routinely
inspect these or randomly inspect
that would help out the town certainly
to give us a better handle on exactly
what's going on i mean because i've
witnessed on a couple of
raids that i was involved with where you
go in and you've got the second floor of
these commercial buildings being
utilized for living space with literally
buckets at the end of the beds for
sanitation and so forth so
it's a it's a tough problem right now
thank you very much could you give us a
pink card when you're uh a minute
thank you madam chair and just a quick
question so
you're basically you're here today
asking that
massage establishments
be licensed no different than a
barber shop or nail salon so that the
facility can be inspected to make sure
those that are there operating
that are supposed to be licensed are
licensed and doing what they're supposed
to be doing is that what i'm hearing yes
representative schmidt
good afternoon mr mackie so um
do you have any therapeutic massage
practitioners in this in the town of
dairy
i would assume that we do that are
associated with some of the medical
facilities we do have a lot of medical
office use in the town and parkland
hospital and so forth
follow-up
do they have any uh comparable
activity or
or
facilities to the ones that we're
talking about the
what might be called illegal massage not
to my knowledge no
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
ah
thank you mr porter for uh coming back
you you don't have a copy of the bill
that will require my reading glasses
oh
okay
okay page three so this this has to do
with um
like penalties you know it says it's
misdemeanor if you don't have your
license but on line seven can you
explain that that option
sole proprietors don't need an
establishment license but
in this section it says if a sole
proprietor or
is providing services without prior
appointment
the proprietor
like what
i i can't i can't but i don't know if
representative growth can i
i'm trying to put this
into
i just need to re-read it to make sure
and and and on top of that that would be
like a walk-in where you put up your
sign you know
massage
right now serving or whatever
that's how i would interpret i just i
would have to take more time to digest
that and get back to you because i need
to read it in totality with the rest of
the statute and yeah i don't like to
isolate too too much
okay it just it just seems to you know
at the beginning we have a definition of
sole proprietor
and it's in
and they don't
just it seems just seems odd to me i
just wonder if you could some somebody
needs to explain like why is that even
there so that's all
thank you very much for for uh looking
into that for us sure
thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right seeing none i will close the
public hearing
and i believe this will be going to
we're through for the day
everyone is welcome back on thursday for
licensing day two
to be continued
and i will send out to the committee a
you